bonjour à tous nous reprenons donc notre
cycle
d'audition aujourd'hui dans cette salle
dont on a déjà noté hier qu'elle pouvait
être très chaude et donc vous êtes tous
bien sûr autorisés à tomber la veste si
les nécessités vous en font loi je suis
très heureux d'accueillir aujourd'hui
pour ouvrir cette deè ce deuxè
après-midi d'audition monsieur Clément
bon ministre délégué en charge des
transport monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie de vous être rendu disponible
dès le début de nos travaux cette
audition est en effet la 4e à laquelle
nous procédons euh la Commission
européenne a annoncé le 13 janvier
dernier l'ouverture d'une enquête
approfondie sur les mesures de soutien
du gouvernement français en faveur de la
filiale fret de la SNCF sur la période
2007-2019 craignant que certaines
d'entre ellees n'est pas été conforme
aux règles communautaires en matière
d'aide d'État la société frit SNCF a été
en effet constamment déficitaire sauf en
2021 et 2022 elle a vu ses pertes
continuellement couvertes par sa société
maère pendant la période de 2000 7 à
2019 grâce à des avances de trésorerie
en interne du groupe trois mesures
seraient spécifiquement visé par la
Commission et nous y reviendrons bien
sûr dans votre audition d'une part des
avances de trésorerie d'un montant de 4
à 4,3 milliards d'euros destinés à
compenser le déficit d'exploitation
récurrent de frais TNCF d'autre part
l'annulation de la dette financière de
frais TNCF d'un montant de 5,3 milliards
d'euros par voie législative en 2019 au
moment de sa transformation en société
et l'injection d'un CAP t de 170
millions d'euros réalisés en 2019 plutôt
que d'attendre que ce risque contentieux
aboutisse à une condamnation de fr SNCF
et probablement à sa faillite le
gouvernement a annoncé le 23 mai dernier
en même temps que des mesures très
significatives de soutien au frit de
ferroviaire qu'il retenait une solution
de discontinuité pour préserver une
activité de fret ferroviaire publique il
s'agirait de faire succéder à SNCF fret
au 1er janvier 2025 deux sociétés l'une
chargée de l'activité capacitaire et
l'autre de la maintenance des
locomotives pour éviter que les
nouvelles sociétés soient jugées trop
proches de frait SNCF et donc
responsable des éventuels pénalité que
ce dernier pourrait se voir infligé 23
flux de trains entiers soit 30 % du
trafic devrait être cédé à d'autres
entreprises ainsi que 62 locomotives
vendues nous souhaitons vous entendre
monsieur le ministre sur l'analyse du
risque d'une condamnation de frait SNCF
qui vous a conduit à retenir cette
solution sur l'état de l'enquête
approfondie lancée le 18 janvier
sur l'inquiétude suscitée par ce
changement majeur du périmètre de
l'activité de fretes ferroviair publ
pour les objectifs de décarbonation des
transports sur les effets de la
stratégie nationale de développement du
fret ferroviaire annoncé en 2021 ainsi
que sur votre vision des perspectives
actuellement ouvertes au secteur du fret
ferroviaire par la préoccupation
constante des entreprises et croissante
sur leur impact carbone cette audition
je le précise est retransmise en direct
sur le site de l'Assemblée nationale est
également et de façon un peu
exceptionnelle en visionférence même si
je sais que pour les services de
l'Assemblée cela demande un travail
supplémentaire et l'enregistrement vidéo
sera ensuite disponible bien sûr
j'indique à nos collègues qu'ils peuvent
participer à distance à notre réunion en
utilisant le lien qui leur a été envoyé
ce matin monsieur le ministre je vous
laisserai la parole pour une
intervention liminaire d'une quinzaine
de minutes au paravant je vous rappelle
que l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au f fement des
assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter le
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité je vous invite
donc à lever la main droite et à dire je
le
jure je le jure monsieur le Président je
vous remerci monsieur le ministre vous
avez donc la parole pour une quinzaine
de
minutes merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés merci
d'avoir permis cette audition et d'avoir
souhaité m'entendre vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président dès le début de
vos travaux sur un sujet d'importance je
crois que chacun en convient un défi
majeur j'ai reviendrai aussi qui
consiste à organiser sécuriser l'avenir
du fret ferroviaire dans notre pays et
plus largement en Europe au moment de la
transition écologique je commencerai si
vous me le permettez par ce point
puisqueon va m'interroger sur la vision
que je porte que le gouvernement porte
pour le développement non seulement la
préservation mais je dis bien le
développement du fret ferroviaire et
c'est évidemment dans ce ce contexte-là
que nous devons répondre et dans cette
vision d'ensemble à une difficulté
majeure ne le cachons pas et je
reviendrai en détail aussi en répondant
ensuite à toutes vos questions qui est
la procédure ouverte par la Commission
européenne depuis le mois de janvier de
cette année d'abord je veux le dire avec
beaucoup de force j'ai une conviction
très profonde dans l'avenir du fra
ferroviaire et son développement ne nous
cachons pas les choses les 20 dernières
années ont été difficiles en matière de
frites ferroviaires et je crois que ça
ne
commence pas avec la procédure que nous
sommes en train d'affronter si je puis
le dire mais l'avenir est important et
l'avenir est ouvert pour le frais de
ferroviaire et je le dis avec cette
conviction je reviendrai sur un certain
nombre d'éléments d'investissement de
soutien au secteur que nous portons ce
gouvernement ou son prédécesseur depuis
plusieurs années et que j'ai souhaité
renforcer aussi ce printemps par
l'annonce de mesure d'aide à à
l'exploitation et au fonctionnement et
d'investissements qui sont essentiels et
donc je le dis avec beaucoup de force il
n'y a ni SAB
ni abandon ni résignation sur la
situation où l'avenir du fra de
ferroviaire et y compris du frait
ferroviaire public dans notre pays nous
y croyons c'est difficile mais nous
voyons d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
signaux positifs d'augmentation
notamment de la part du frit ferroviaire
ces deux dernières années dans le
transport global de marchandis dans
notre pays et on voit je crois que ça a
été évoqué d'ailleurs devant votre
commission hier chez les acteurs privés
ou publics chez les entreprises qui ont
besoin de transporter leurs marchandises
qui sont sont les clients finaux du fret
un appétit de recourir au fret
ferroviaire au moment de la transition
écologique et donc je veux le dire
vraiment nous avons des perspectives
positives pour le fret ferroviaire et
l'État les soutiens et les soutiendra
j'y insiste sur ce point je crois que ça
nous réunit par-delà les différentes
sensibilités politiques d'ailleurs le
Parlement au moment du vote de la loi
dite climat résilience a fixé des
objectif qui s'impose au gouvernement et
l'oblige à définir et à mettre en œuvre
une stratégie pour se faire consistant
en un doublement de la part modale du
fret ferroviaire dans le transport de
marchandis de notre pays passant de 9 %
au moment du vote de la loi à 18 % à la
fin de cette décennie nous avons déployé
une stratégie nationale avant que je
sois au responsabilité mais je m'inscris
dans cette continuité qui en découle qui
est composé de 73 mesures précises je ne
vous les listerai pas toutes mais elles
sont importantes et aujourd'hui il y a
eu un comité de pilotage comme il y en a
régulièrement encore au mois de juin et
et nous avons vu que la moitié des
mesures étaient aujourd'hui mis en œuvre
en totalité ou partiellement nous
pourrons y revenir sur certaines d'entre
elles mais il y a cet engagement et je
le disais nous voyons à travers les
aides augmenté par le plan de relance à
travers cette stratégie nationale du
fret que déjà nous avons un certain
nombre de bonnes nouvelles même si ces
signaux il faut être prudent ambitieux
mais prudent sont fragile le fr
ferroviaire a atteint son meilleur
niveau de parmodale dans le transport de
marchandis l'an dernier depuis 2017 près
de 11 % et son meilleur niveau de trafic
depuis presqueun décennie depuis 2015 à
près de 36 milliards de tonnes
transporté par la voie ferroviaire vous
me permettrez de me concentrer sur les
annonces que j'ai faites dans le
prolongement de cette stratégie dans le
cadre de ce plan pour l'amplifier au
moment précis évidemment les choses sont
liées j'y reviendrai où nous avons dû
répondre à la procédure de la Commission
Européenne j'ai décidé nous avons
mobilisé des des aides au fonctionnement
des aides à l'exploitation
supplémentaire elles ont été renforcées
je le disais au moment du plan de
relance très significativement plus 160
millions d'euros par an depuis le plan
de relance de la fin de l'année 2020 ces
aides non seulement seront pérennisées
j'avais eu l'occasion d'indiquer devant
le Parlement qu'elles étaient prolongées
jusqu'à 2027 l'échéance initiale était
prévu en 2024 j'ai eu l'occasion de
préciser je le redis devant votre
commission qu'elles seront prolongées au
moins jusqu'en 2030 ce qui est
nécessaire pour le la visibilité c'est
un des facteurs clés du développement du
fra de ferroviaire à l'ensemble des
acteurs elles seront elles seront pardon
pérénisé elles seront aussi amplifier
augmenter nous aurons l'occasion de
mener la discussion budgétaire dans
quelques semaines de 30 millions d'euros
par an à partir de la fin de l'année
prochaine de l'annuité 2025 ce qui fera
pardon pour ces chiffres je résume un
total de 330 de 300 millions pardon de
de d'aide annuelle pour l'exploitation
du fra de ferroviaire là où nous étions
à moins de la moitié il y a encore 2 ans
tout cela sur une décennie c'est un
total de près d'un milliard d'euros
d'investissement supplémentaire par
rapport à ce qui était encore en vigueur
en 2020 donc je crois que c'est un
effort très important ces
aidesexloitation je ne détaille pas mais
beaucoup d'entre vous les connaissez ce
sont des aides au vagons isolés ce sont
des aides au péag pour développer ou
lever des barrières au développement du
fret
ferroviaire je le disais aussi nous
devons compléter ces aides à
l'exploitation et ces aides au
fonctionnement par des aides à
l'investissement et si nous faisons un
peu de retour en arrière force de
constater deux choses je le disais
brièvement d'abord le déclin du frit de
ferroviaire dans le transport de
marchandise de notre pays n'est pas lié
je le dis on aura peut-être ce débat à
la libéralisation du frit de ferroviaire
que nous avons mené en France comme au
niveau européen les chiffres le montrent
le déclin était très fortement engagé je
pour aller détailler précisément depuis
le début de l'année 2000 au moins et
entre 2000 et 2006 2005 2006 quand la
l'ouverture à la concurrence se fait je
préfère d'ailleurs utiliser ce terme il
est plus précis il y avait déjà une
perte sur ces années-là de près de 30 %
de l'activité du fra de ferroviaire en
France dans le transport total de
marchandises dans notre pays donc on
peut avoir un débat sur savoir si on
avait raison de faire cette réforme ou
pas qui a été porté je le disais au
niveau européen mais en tout cas il faut
être clair ça n'est pas été la seule
mesure je fais lien avec
l'investissement si vous me le permettez
car je crois que ce qui a manqué
globalement not stratégie et ces choix
peuvent se comprendre je crois que
monsieur janté l'a évoqué hier aussi
c'est que nous avons traditionnellement
en France privilégié deux choses dans le
système ferroviaire privilégieré le
trafic de voyageurs au trafic de
marchandises ce choix peut s'expliquer
nous voulons aussi développer évidemment
l'usage du train pour nos concitoyens
mais il a des impacts il a eu des
impacts sur le développement du fret et
nous avons parfois privilégié avec de
bonnes intentions les différents
gouvernements et les différentes
majorités les aides au fonctionnement
qui reste nécessaire aux aides à
l'investissement au projet
d'investissement et si je dois mettre
l'accent sur un point pour engager
renforcer le développement du frit
ferroviaire dans les années qui viennent
c'est que nous devons faire plus en
matière d'investissement notamment dans
nos grandes gardes de triage je pense à
Miramas monsieur le Président zouisi je
le dis car nous l'avons visité ensemble
et que l'État investit beaucoup la gare
de voapi en Moselle tout cela dans le
cadre des contrats de plan état région
notamment nous allons y pourvoir avec un
cadruplement de l'investissement qui est
prévu dans 7 génération de contrats de
plan État-région volet mobilité par
rapport à la génération précédente comme
vous le savez ces contrats sont en cours
de négociation avec les régions mais
dans la part de l'État nous avions nous
avons bien prévu cette multiplication
par 4 des crédits d'investissement qui
me semble plus important encore pour
donner un seul chiffre le plan que j'ai
présenté au mois de mai consiste à
engager 4 milliards d'euros
d'investissement pas seulement de l'État
environ la moitié pour l'État je crois
que les régions et les autres
collectivités sont prêtes à s'engager
elles l'ont déjà montré 4 milliards
d'euros t sur une décennie entre 2023 et
2032 j'insiste beaucoup parce que si
nous croyons au développement du FR
ferroviaire c'est en améliorant nos
infrastructures ce n'est pas vrai que
pour le fret mais c'est particulièrement
vrai pour le fret que nous donnerons un
avenir au fret ferroviaire durablement
et massivement alors l'état n'abandonne
aucun cas le frais ferroviaire parce
qu'il investit et parce qu'il soutient
l'exploitation les opérateurs mais vous
le disiez et ça a justifié monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président je
crois les travaux de C Commission en
partie c'est l'actualité difficile jeose
le dire douloureuse de la procédure
ouverte par la Commission européenne à
l'égard de notre pays comme de plusieurs
autres États-membres d'ailleurs mais
pour ce qui nous concerne depuis le mois
de janvier
2023 j'aurai l'occasion j'imagine de
détailler dans les réponses à vos
interrogations un certain nombre
d'éléments mais je veux en donner
quelques-uns dès cette introduction
d'abord cette procédure est-elle une
bonne chose je suis un Européen
convaincu je n'ai pas l'habitude de de
critiquer les institutions européennes
mais il y a des choix et je ne partage
pas l'idée que cette procédure était une
bonne chose je regrette son ouverture
mais je ne peux pas faire comme si les
faits n'était pas là et donc je le dis
aussi cette procédure nous avons cherché
je pourrais y revenir très précisément
je suis mis des transports depuis 14
mois les choses ont commencé avant mais
j'ai moi-même eu l'occasion de discuter
avant l'ouverture de la procédure avec
la commission euren pour essayer de
l'éviter de faire valoir nos arguments
mais les choses ont changé évidemment à
partir du 18 janvier 2023 et donc je le
dis aussi sur le fond cette procédure
c'est ça le démarrage je crois des choix
politiques qu'il faut discuter fait
peser un risque existentiel vital sur
l'opérateur frit SNCF l'opérateur de
frit ferroviair public en France qui
n'est pas le seul mais qui est
évidemment central et il est pour moi
très clair que nous ne pouvons pas nous
dispenser d'un opérateur ferroviaire
public d' opérateur ferroviaire public
de référence dans notre système de fret
ferroviaire et donc ce qui a guidé
l'action du gouvernement c'est qui a
guidé mon action c'est d'agir je crois
en responsabilité face à ce risque
existentiel et je le partage avec vous
très librement comme j'ai l'occasion de
le faire avec les organisations
syndicales moi-même avec la direction de
l'entreprise évidemment sur le terrain
nous avions une alternative je crois que
il y a deux options essentiellement face
à cette procédure une option consistait
à aller au bout de la procédure
c'est un choix possible il y a toujours
des alternatives c'est un choix possible
aller au bout de la procédure on ne sait
jamais combien de temps dure cette
procédure mais l'expérience des
procédures européennes montre que c'est
sans doute 18 à 24 mois sans compter des
recours possibles et donc je le dis avec
une forte conviction et une totale
sincérité je crois que nous aurions
condamné Fred SNCF dès maintenant pu
puisque prenons cette hypothèse de 18
mois elle est très basse nous aurions eu
pendant 18 mois au moins une incertitude
sur le maintien même en vie économique
de notre opérateur central de fret
ferroviaire je rappelle que ce qui est
en jeu infin c'est une demande c'est en
tout cas ce qui a motivé l'ouverture de
la procédure par les autorités de la
Commission européenne d'un remboursement
estime la commission de 5,3 milliards
d'euros d'aide jug
estimé
illégal et je le dis par avance le
principe même du remboursementunen c'est
que c'est l'entreprise qui en a
bénéficié quel que soit son statut qui
doit la rembourser donc c'est pas l'état
français ce serait déjà pas une paille
c'est l'entreprise qui serait tenu si on
allait au bout de cette procédure avec
cette issul de rembourser 5,3 milliards
d'euros j'insiste sur ce point parce que
le risque vital est double à mon sens le
risque vital c'est évidemment de devoir
rembourser tout tout partie de cette
somme et même si c'est la moitié ou les
3/4 c'est majeur et insoutenable mais
c'est surtout plus encore dès maintenant
le fait que l'incertitude est mortelle
parce que
l'incertitude oblige à dire aux clients
aux entreprises qui veulent faire
transporter le marchandise écoutez nous
ne pouvons pas vous garantir que dans 6
mois 9 mois 12 mois 18 mois nous aurons
encore la capacité de transporter tel ou
tel type de marchandise et donc jeiniste
parce que
dans partage avec vous le raisonnement
et la responsabilité que j'endosse en
tant que ministre c'est un paramètre
essentiel qui a faiser dans le choix
l'autre option l'autre branche de cette
alternative celle que je préconise de
suivre et que je suis aujourd'hui c'est
de trouver le plus vite possible et
j'insiste sur l'idée non pas de
précipitation mais d'urgence c'est de
trouver le plus vite possible un accord
avec la Commission européenne pour lever
le
risque je présente les choses de la
manière la plus transparente et complète
possible c'est la décision sans doute je
permettrai de le dire ainsi une seconde
la plus difficile que j'ai eu à prendre
dans ma courte vie ministérielle et dans
ma vie professionnelle parce que je sais
ce qu'il y a derrière des emplois un
opérateur un service public mais je suis
convaincu que à certaines conditions que
je vais brièvement
détailler trouver un accord et lever
l'incertitude rapidement et le meilleur
facteur en l'accompagnant d'un plan
d'investissement tel que je l'ai décrit
en l'accompagnant de ce plan
d'investissement non seulement de
sauvegarde mais de développp du FR
ferroviaire y compris par l'opérateur
public par un opérateur public dans les
années qui viennent et donc nous avons
eu cette discussion avec la Commission
européenne pour déterminer puisque
ensuite la décision c'est une procédure
juridique appartient à la Commission
européenne ce qui est du point de vue de
la France et du gouvernement de la
France les lignes rouges dans lesquelles
nous nous inscrivons si nous négocions
et ce qui serait susceptibleévidemment
il faut réunir les deux critères
d'obtenir un accord et pas une procédure
dur qui aboutirait au remboursement le
but c'est évidemment d'éviter cela et et
de préserver des
conditions positive favorable en tout
cas moins défavorable que d'autres pour
le frais de ferroviaire et donc il y a
trois axes qui motive cette position de
négociation ferme l'un l'emploi il est
évident qu'il faut préserver au maximum
l'emploi dans un opérateur ferroviaire
public je vais revenir sur ce point dans
les années qui viennent et donc la
solution qui est en envisager sur
laquelle nous sommes prêts à prendre des
engagements auprès de la Commission
européenne pour lever le risque c'est
d'avoir un maintien maximal de l'emploi
et dans la solution qui a été présentée
par l'entreprise notamment aux instances
représentatives du personnel ce qui est
évoqué c'est 90 % de l'emploi maintenu
dans une structure de frais de
ferroviair public qui succéderait à frit
et SNCF dans ce qu'on appelle une
discontinuité raisonnée raisonnable
2uxème critère très important c'est de
garder précisément c'est pour ça que
j'ai insisté sur ces termes un opérateur
ferroviaire public ce ne sera pas
exactement la structure actuelle ça
s'appelle justement cette discontinuité
je ne le cache pas mais c'est un
opérateur ferroviaire public dans le
sens où son capital doit et peut rester
majoritairement ou très majoritairement
même public c'est essentiel et
d'ailleurs je le dis c'est ma conviction
profonde qu'il faut garder un opérateur
de frait de ferroviaire public et je
crois d'ailleurs que beaucoup d'acteurs
clients chargeurs mais aussi d'autres
opérateurs de fret
privés
ne souhaite pas qu'il y a la disparition
d'un opérateur ferroviaire public de
référence car c'est essentiel à
l'organisation la structuration la
visibilité du marché du frais de
ferroviaire et donc je suis convaincu
pour toutes ces raisons j'allais dire de
principes et de valeurs mais aussi
d'efficacité écologique économique que
nous avons besoin d'un opérateur de Fra
de ferroviaire public c'est la deuxième
condition que je veux poser dans cette
discussion la troisème c'est évidemment
d'éviter le report modal et donc qu'on
puisse continuer à investir dans le
secteur du fret de ferroviaire y compris
public j'ai pas détaillé l'ensemble des
aides à l'explloitation tout à l'heure
mais je l'ai dit il y a évidemment dans
ce paquet dans l'augmentation des aides
que je propose pour 2025 2024- 2025 des
aides au wagons isolés on sait que c'est
un des éléments qui sera au cœur de
l'opérateur ferroviaire publ ce qu'on
appelle les trains mutualisés la gestion
capacitaire qu'il faut continuer à
soutenir et donc c'est le troisème
élément il faut éviter évidemment tout
report modal inversé ce serait absurde
au moment de ce que la Commission
européenne appelle le Green Deal le
pacte vert de ce que nous faisons tous y
compris dans notre pays et avant tout
notre pays pour l'écologie la transition
écologique d'avoir une mise en danger du
secteur du fredes ferroviaire y compris
public mais plus largement je crois que
si nous arrivons à préserver ces trois
conditions avec des efforts je ne l'ai
pas caché non plus et d'ailleurs ça a
été présenté de manière détaillée
transparente car tel est le droit
heureusement aux aux instances pardon
représentatives du personnel par la
direction de l'entreprise que je crois
vous interrogerez aussi il y aura des
activités à céder
environ 20 % du chiffre d'affaires
actuel il y aura des emplois qui devront
quitter la structure actuelle mais
j'insiste sur ce point social et de
l'emploi il est évident que aucun de ces
emplois ne sera supprimé au sens où il
quitterait le groupe SNCF dans son
ensemble et j'ai demandé au PDG de SNCF
de veiller à ce que tout le monde a une
solution au sein du groupe unifié et
d'ailleurs qu'il y ait je crois que ça
vous sera dit par les dirigeants
d'entreprise de manière là aussi sans
doute plus précise que pour les années
qui viennent puisque j'anticipe nous
anticipons et nous nous mettons en
mesure d'avoir un développement du fra
de ferroviaire y compris pour
l'opérateur ferroviaire public qui est
une priorité d'emploi pour les gens qui
ont travaillé ces dernières années au
sein de l'entreprise fret
SMCF je le dit c'est une décision
compliquée c'est un dossier compliqué la
vision d'ensemble c'est pas la procédure
que nous devons affronter j'ose espérer
que c'est un épisode aussi difficile
soit-il la vision l'ensemble c'est le
développement du frais de ferroviaire
public nous devons surmonter cet épisode
pour ne pas gâcher
sur le plan social écologique industriel
le développement du frais de ferroviaire
public je
pourrais peut-être ne serions-nous pas
là faire le choix de la procrastination
et de la facilité laisser la procédure
se dérouler ça prend je le disais 18
mois 2 ans peut-être plus sans doute
plus d'ailleurs si on utilise toutes les
voies de recours ce serait plus
confortable objectivement ce serait plus
facile et donc je le dis l'opération qui
consiste à avoir une discontinuité dans
le cadre ainsi défini et dans les lignes
roues ainsi rappelé n'est pas facile
mais je crois que c'est le choix de
responsabilité c'est en tout cas
l'évaluation que j'ai faite accompagner
d'un plan d'investissement majeur pour
que nous ayons rapidement des
perspectives garanties pour un opérateur
de frais de ferroviaire public pour
l'ensemble du secteur du frais de
ferroviaire et un soutien financier je
le dis puisque nous avons connu des
épisodes plus compliqués validé par la
commission européenne de manière claire
pour le développement du fret
ferroviaire dans les années qui viennent
voilà monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur ces premiers éléments que je
voulais rappeler en introduction il me
semble je voulais tout à fait précis
avoir hésité entre un total de 300
millions d'euros par an et de 330
millions d'euros par an pour les aides à
l'exploitation telles que elles sont
issues du plan que j'ai annoncé au mois
de mai c'est bien un total de 330
millions d'euros par an qui est permis
par ce plan d'investissement à partir de
2025 et au moins jusqu'à
merci merci monsieur le ministre vous
avez beaucoup insisté sur la pétence
plus forte aujourd'hui qu'elle ne
pouvait l'être par le passé de des
entreprises pour le la solution fret
notamment pour décarboner leur mobilité
et c'est un point sur lequel
effectivement Patrick Jantet ancien
président de SNCF réseau a également
beaucoup insisté hier quelques question
pour ouvrir ce ce dialogue avant de
donner la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur après que vous m'aurait
répondu d'abord vous
évoqueiez les les chargeurs et
l'incertitude dans laquelle il pourrait
se trouver pour ceux qui travaillent
avec Fred SNCF si d'aventure on laissait
la procédure suivre son cours si le
gouvernement français avait fait ce
choix euh pouvez-vous euh j'imagine que
vous avez un dialogue avec ces chargeurs
et pouvez-vous partager avec nous la
manière dont ils lisent la solution qui
a été choisie par le gouvernement de
discon ité et et le niveau d'inquiétude
qui peut exister ici et là chez certains
d'entre eux deuxème question sur le le
la gestion capacitaire qui qui est
aujourd'hui dans l'activité dans le
chiffre d'affaires et dans le personnel
de fret
SNCF la gestion enfin l'activité
principale comment voyez-vous l'avenir
de cette gestion capacitaire son modèle
économique sachant qu'il s'agit
également du segment le plus dépendant
aux aides
publiques 3oème question sur
l'investissement vous avez parlé de la
nécessité d'investir à la fois dans les
infrastructure mais aussi dans les
matériels pour développer le le frit
ferroviaire on sait d'ailleurs qu'il y a
un problème du point de vue de
l'acquisition de locomotive frit et de
la valorisation des des c2euf mais je
voulais vous interroger sur un point que
vous avez évoqué c'est-à-dire la volonté
la capacité des régions à s'engager au
côté de l'État dans l'investissement sur
les infrastructures 100 % frit ou en
partie dédié au fret est-ce que cette
appétence des régions pour les
investissements en faveur du fret est
égale selon les différentes régions
françaises on a cru comprendre que ça
n'était pas complètement le cas et puis
enfin dernière question sur les points
de comparaison européens au regard de ce
soutien public qui a été exercé en
faveur de de fret SNCF puisque on a pu
lire ici et là que dB cargot avait
également un dialogue nourri avec la
Commission européenne je vous remercie
par avance de vos réponses
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
j'essaie de répondre à questions dans
l'ordre sur la question des chargeurs
ceux qui sont clients aujourd'hui de
Fred SNCF ont reçu par l'entreprise la
notification à la fin du mois de juillet
que il y aurait sans doute discontinuité
nouvelle entreprise pas rien une
nouvelle entreprise qui conservera
l'essentiel de l'activité je reviendrai
sur la gestion capacitaire
et le préciderera sans doute mais je
crois que beaucoup de de clients qui
sont chargeurs souhaitent rester client
de l'entreprise publique succédera à
Fret SNCF
et un délai jusqu'à la fin de l'année
avait été évoqué pour assurer cette
bascule et ce délai peut-être prolongé
sans risque juridique jusqu'au 30 juin
2024 au moins pour donner une visibilité
le temps de se réorganiser je dis il y a
à la fois urgence à donner de la
visibilité c'est ça que demande les
chargeurs je crois pouvoir le dire très
clairement savoir ce qui se passe donc
si on attend si on ne sait pas il est
clair que la situation est moins bonne
pour eux et que dans j'allais dire le
moins mauvais des scénarios ils
choisiront potentiellement un autre
acteur du fraide ferroviaire s'ils le
peuvent et dans le pire des scénarios
ils choisiront un autre mode de
transport donc c'est très important de
ne pas avoir de rupture et de donner
vite cette visibilité tout en assurant
le temps évidemment qui est le temps de
la discussion interne à l'entreprise qui
est le temps de la réorganisation pour
que l'opérateur soit frit de ferroviaire
succédant à frit SNCF soit en place à ce
stade à ma connaissance il n'y a pas
d'alerte sur des mouvements de basculle
vers d'autres modes de transport ou
d'inquiétude majeure sur l'existence
même d'une entreprise telle que frit
SNCF pour l'avenir si vous me permettez
un commentaire supplémentaire il y a la
question des chargeurs et puis la
question de l'ensemble des opérateurs de
fret Fret SNCF est déjà en concurrence
sur le marché national et l'ensemble des
acteurs du Fred dont Fret SNCF
d'ailleurs demandait de longues dates un
plan d'investissement que les
représentants du secteur le 4F ont
chiffré jusqu'à 2030 le début de la
prochaine décennie à peu près 3,5
milliards d'euros je dis ça parce que je
crois pouvoir dire que nous avons
répondu et même plus que répondu à cette
attente ce qu'on avait jamais fait dans
cette ampleur en proposant qu'il y ait 4
milliards d'euros d'investissement pas
seulement les allées d'explloitation
pérenisé renforcé 4 milliards d'euros
d'aide d'investissement notamment pour
not triage d'ici le début de la décenie
ce qui me permet de faire le lien je
reviendrai sur la gestion capacitaire
avec la pétence des régions ces 4
milliards d'euros d'investissement ils
sont nécessairement partenariots l'État
est prêt à en mettre environ la moitié
ce qui je le redis est quatre fois plus
que dans la génération précédente de CPR
pour cette génération de CPR 23 27 et la
suivante et ce que je vois même si la
négociation est en cours et je ne veux
pas parler à la place des prés en région
mais c'est que la pétence est réelle
dans tous les mandats de région concerné
par des infrastructures de fraes
ferroviair la première ministre et
moi-même avons ont indiqué au préfet des
enveloppes pour le fra de ferroviaire
c'est ça qui multiplie par 4 et dans les
premiers contacts avec les régions
prendre simplement deux exemples de
régions très concernées parce qu'elles
accueillent des gares de triage très
importantes la plus importante de France
est dans la région Grand Est à voapi je
le disais pour pouvoir dire que le
président de région le roi comme
d'autres collectivités d'ailleurs sont
tout à fait prêts à investir et nous
aurons un plan d'investissement de plus
de 80 millions d'euros pour refaire
entièrement la gare de voapi si certains
d'entre vous l'ont visité elle mérite le
mot est faible ce réinvestissement et je
l'évoquais avec le président Zoui la
gare de Miramas autre Gard de triage
emblématique est importante fait déjà
l'objet depuis 2021 avec le soutien de
plusieurs collectivités dans la région
d'un plan d'investissement qui porte ses
fruits et qui sera poursuivi à hauteur
de plus de 40 millions d'euros donc je
crois pouvoir dire que du côté des
régions principalement mais aussi des
collectivités c'est le cas par exemple
première mass où le département et la
ville mettent de l'argent nous avons de
quoi atteindre ses objectifs
d'investissement et l'État fera
évidemment plus que sa part au moins la
moitié de cet investissement sur la
gestion capacitaire et son avenir oui
j'y crois ces trains mutualisés qui sont
le cœur de l'activité ce qu'on appelle
le wagon isolé qui est une partie plus
réduite que la gestion capacitaire dans
son ensemble ça reste indispensable
d'avoir un acteur de référence pour le
faire c'est aujourd'hui frit SNCF ça
devra rester un acteur du fret
ferroviaire public demain et c'est
notamment c'est lié évidemment à la
stratégie d'investissement pour cette
raison car ce sont aujourd'hui je crois
les principaux points de faiblesse que
nous réinvestissons dans
l'infrastructure de triage c'est ça
aussi qui garantit un marché économique
pour la gestion capacitaire et nous
savons que avec le
développement des exigences écologiques
la pétence croissante sur le marché du
transport de marchandise pour le frais
de
ferroviaire le vagon isolé les train
mutualisés sont essentiels la gestion
capacitaire est essentielle donc il faut
un opérateur
et euh nous savons aussi que nous
devrons je le disais développer ces
infrastructures mais aussi le transport
combiné et là aussi j'y insiste parce
que Fret SNCF a développé maintenant
depuis quelques années une capacité à
être un acteur du transport combiné rail
route ce qui fait en fait que le rail se
développe puisque le dernier kilomètre
peut-être assuré par la route sinon il y
a pas de solution et donc sur ces deux
points je crois vraiment un avenir
économique important du fra de
ferroviaire et de l'opérateur de Fra
ferroviaire public en son centre sur
les comparaisons européennes j'entends
des comparaisons dont je veux dire
que semble que beaucoup de gens et
beaucoup d'information que même le
gouvernement allemand n'est
pas puisqueon parle souvent de DB cargo
il y a une procédure m parartient pas de
commenter une procédure juridique
ouverte à l'égard d'un autre étatmembre
mais enfin ce qu'on sait c'est qu' une
procédure qui est ouverte à l'encontre
de l'opérateur allemand ce qu'on sait
aussi c'est que l'opérateur allemand
n'est pas tout à fait dans la même
situation que l'opérateur français Fred
SNCF puisque
si je simplifie un peu les becargo se
voir reprocher des choses qui nous nous
ont été reproché en
2005 au moment où nous avons réorganisé
le frait de ferroviaire d'une première
façon donc c'est pas une situation
comparable à celle que vit aujourd'hui
au type d'aide qui est reproché à l'état
français d'avoir été versé à l'opérateur
Fred
SNCF donc la situation n'est pas tout à
fait comparable et je crois pouvoir dire
néanmoins que les autorités allemandes
évidemment non pas me faire connaître
les détails mais discute pour ne pas
dire négocie aussi avec les autorités
européennne pour préserver leur
opérateur et donc pour le dire
clairement je ne crois pas du tout à
cette fable de l'opposition entre une
France qui se serait couché devant des
injonctions
bruxelloises très franchement je peux
revenir sur chacun des rendez-vous que
j'ai eu depuis de longs mois de longues
années pour défendre les intérêts de
notre fr de ferroviaire publi de notre
entreprise notre service public qu avoir
les discussions sur le fond mais je
pense pouvoir démontrer et l'engagement
et la sincérité et les autorités
allemandes sont aussi en train de
discuter dans des paramètres et des
discussions des types d'Aid qui ne sont
pas les mêmes et pas le même montant
d'ailleurs que ce qui est reproché entre
guillemets à l'opérateur et aux
autorités françaises et nous savons
qu'il y a d'autres cas je n'en ferai pas
la liste complète mais qui aboutissent
aussi à des réflexions sur des solutions
de discontinuité du même ordre c'est le
cas de la Roumanie qui a aussi une
procédure
à l'égard de son opérateur de fret
ferroviaire voilà monsieur le Président
pour essayer de répondre le plus
précisément possible à vos quatre
interrogations merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre je donne la parole à
Monsieur le
Rapporteur bienvenue je
m'associe au président quelques
premières questions pour ma part
euh au regard de vos fonctions monsieur
le ministre en lien direct avec les
affaires européennes depuis 2016 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui à divers titres
euh pouvez-vous nous dire quand vous
avez eu connaissance
ou vous avez été intéressé au
dossier contentieux préconentieux Fred
SNCF Commission européenne quand
exactement avez-vous eu à connaître et à
y être intéressé deuxième question au
moment de l'adoption du pacte
ferroviaire et de la transformation donc
de l'pic en sa fret
stncf est-ce que votre collègue des
transports vous-même au titre de vos
responsabilités vous vous êtes assuré de
la viabilité pérenne de la nouvelle sa
qui était donc créée euh la SA Fret SNCF
au regard justement du contentieux en
germe ou déjà établi au travers des
échanges d'informations depuis 2017
entre la France et l'Europe avec la
Commission européenne je dis cela
sachant que à la lecture des éléments de
la Commission européenne c'est bien sa
Fret SNCF qui est désigné comme ayant
été porté
artificiellement du fait du retrait de
la dette comme sur le sur le marché 3e
question lors du du prer semestre
2022 la France préside l'Union
européenne et entend faire du fret je
cite c'est dans la stratégie nationale
enentant faire du fret
euh un sujet majeur ma question est la
suivante est-ce que le dossier est sa
Fret SNCF a été traité d'une quelconque
manière durant ces 6 mois de présidence
européenne de la France sachant que la
France avait posé le fret comme un sujet
majeur nonobstant la question des aides
qui avait été au niveau européen qui
avait été porté euh par la France et 15
autres pays européens euh 4è question
euh alors rapidement la procédure vous
nous avez effectivement indiqué que vous
aviez tranché entre deux options euh et
que pour vous-même vous pensiez
qu'il convenait de trouver un accord
pour
lever le risque dites-vous
euh c'est bien entendu mais
euh vous avez entre les lignes rappelé
que pour la Roumanie pour la Grèce pour
l'Italie pour l'Allemagne des procédures
schelon sur plusieurs
années donc pourquoi une telle urgence
même si vous l'expliquez en indiquant
que le doute pouvait
transansir les chargeurs et les
opérateurs ce doute semble être
aujourd'hui toujours d'actualité puisque
un certain nombre d'opérateurs au sein
de
lafpra bien indique que il ne semble pas
être en capacité de reprendre tout tout
partie des 23 flux qui sont
euh aujourd'hui qui vont devoir être
transférés à la concurrence hors
concurrence rle puisque j'ai cru
comprendre que les opérateurs de rle
étaient n'avait pas concourir sur ces 23
flux euh
excusez-moi de la longueur de mes
questions mais votre présence est
importante et le sujet l'est tout
autant je voudrais savoir s le plan de
discontinuité mais oui vous l'avez dit
mais pour peut-être pourriez-vous
préciser même à l'avenir le détail de de
cette présentation vous avez donc dit
qu' est qu'il avait été
présenté depuis quand et à plusieurs
reprises et négocié avec la Commission
européenne disposez-vous à ce titre à ce
jour d'un agrément
officiel de la Commission européenne ou
de sa présidente qui est aujourd'hui en
en retraite de ses fonctions
euh autre question de plan de de
discontinuité a-t-il fait l'objet
euh ne serait-ce que de
manière interne et officieuse a-t-il
fait l'objet d'une étude d'impact
environnemental justement tout
particulièrement
sur le possible report modal routier
d'une partie des 23 flux
concernés y a-t-il eu au sein de vos
services une étude d'impact ou le début
d'une d'un
examen de cette problématique
qui je le répète semblaêtre sous-jacente
dans le transfert de ces 23 flux enfin
dernière
question l'une des deux nouvelles
sociétés donc serait une entreprise de
transport ferroviaire vous l'avez dit
pour le trafic mutualisé là encore vous
y croyez nous voulons tous y
croire mais avez-vous étudié sa
viabilité vous indiquez effectivement
que cela renvoie à l'effort d'
investissement qui
est qui va être considérable à fournir
et qui n'en est qu'à ses
débuts et
nous aimerions effectivement vous
entendre sur la mise en œuvre des 72
mesures de la stratégie nationale dont
une bonne partie effectivement doivent
porter sur les infrastructures de frite
les ite les triages et cetera et cetera
mais
dont les objectif pour 2021 et 2022 à
court terme euh jusqu'àors n'ont pas
fait l'objet d'une communication
officielle vous avez indiquer tout à
l'heure je crois dans votre introduction
que la moitié des des des des mesures de
ces 72 mesur était atteintes dans leur
objectif euh or elle conditionne bien
évidemment vous le savez le le réseau
l'état du réseau conditionne l'activité
frite en particulier
euh est-ce que vous avez donc étudié
dans ce calendrier court qui est 2030
pour basculer à 18 % de trafic
ferroviaire est-ce que vous
avez étudié cette viabilité à échéence
de 2030 pour atteindre ses objectifs
merci monsieur le ministre pour répondre
à cette première série de
questions merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur je vais essayer aussi d'être
le plus précis possible en réponse à vos
questions
détaillées d'abord sur le le calendrier
de mes fonctions respectives vous me
faites beaucoup d'honneur en disant
depuis 2016 pour être tout à fait précis
mais quelques mois après j'ai j'étais en
2016 en tout cas jusqu'au moin de d'août
2016 me semble-t-il le conseiller pour
différents sujets mais notamment pour
l'Europe du ministre de l'économie de
l'industrie du numérique qui était
Emmanuel Macron je n'ai pas eu à
connaître pour couvrir cette période de
ce sujet dans ses fonctions là mais
c'était assez logique car ça n'était pas
au cœur du secteur ou du périmètre j'ai
été ensuite nommé conseiller pour
l'Europe au sein de la cellule
diplomatique du président de la
République à partir de mai 2017 jusqu'à
l'été 2020 le 26 juillet 2020 si je ne
me trompe euh et de mémoire je n'ai pas
eu à connaître de la question de Fred
SNCF ou de ces procédure plainte puisque
les les premières plaintes datent de
2016 euh
dans le ce cadre là je n'ai pas
travaillé sur ce dossier en revanche
pour être tout à fait précis et complet
j'ai travaillé sur ce dossier alors de
manière plus éloignée que dans ma
responsabilité de ministre des
Transports à
l'évidence mais à partir vous
pardonnerez de ne pas savoir la date
exacte mais je dirais de l'automne 2020
lorsque j'étais dans la fonction de
secrétaire d'État en charge des affaires
européennes au kedoret pourquoi parce
que quand on est secrétaire d'État aux
affaires européenne on a unom de
rendez-vous avec les parlementaires
européens avec les commissaires
européens dont la commissaire à la
concurrence madame westiger euh et donc
j'ai été plusieurs fois en contact avec
celui qui était mon homologue chargé des
transports à l'époque Monsieur J Barry
euh avec notre représentation permanente
avec d'autres acteurs du système
européen et j'ai évoqué ce sujet de
manière assez peu détaillée pour être
tout à fait honnête dans cette
fonctionl je me suis vraiment attaché à
ce dossier puisque là c'était devenu ma
responsabilité centrale à partir du mois
de juillet 2022 en tant que ministre
délégué chargé des transports pour être
le plus précis possible je tiens
évidemment à votre disposition mon
agenda j'ai eu je crois dans la
responsabilité de ministre chargé des
transports six contacts retracés à
l'agenda public d'ailleurs avec la
commissaire westeger ce qui m'amènera à
répondre aussi à la question de
l'urgence ou de la précipitation selon
les mots que vous voulez utiliser vous
avez dit urgence comme comme moi euh
parce que les choses n'ont pas commencé
le 18 janvier 2023 à l'évidence je
refais quelques élément de calendrier en
permettant d'élargir votre question si
je retrace quelques grandes étapes qui
sont essentielles il y a eu des plaintes
déposées par des opérateurs auprès de la
Commission européenne comme c'est leur
droit à partir de l'année 2016 certaines
de ces plaintes même la totalité fin ont
d'ailleurs été
retiré et la Commission a néanmoins
ouvert une procédure c'était donc le 18
janvier 2023 ce qui montre bien que le
jet était profond et sérieux puisque la
commission la
liberté si elle n'a plus de plainte dont
elle est directement saisie d'ouvrir ou
de ne pas ouvrir des procédure si elle
l'ouvre aès juge pas nécessairement
l'issue mais si elle l'ouvre malgré
l'absence de plainte c'est qu'elle
estime et ça rentre en compte notre
appréciation du risque qu'il y a selon
elle une aide massivement illégale ou
fortement à forte présomption
d'illégalité sinon service de la
commission qui sont soumis des
procédures juridiques et même au
contrôle du juge Infiné n'ouvre r
n'ouvre que rarement des procédures
voilà pour vous donner l'état des
discussions elles n'ont pas commencé à
l'évidence le 18 janvier dernier
elles se sont tenues pendant de longs
mois pour éviter une procédure et faire
valoir un nombre d'arguments et puis
ensuite pour répondre j'ai donné
l'alternative qui me semblait être le
résumé de la situation à cette procédure
une fois qu'elle a été ouverte je crois
que vous auditionnerez aussi mon
prédécesseur immédiat Jean-Baptiste
gbari qui a connu les étapes juste
antérieures
sur fer je n'oublie rien mais je prends
un peu dans le désordre pour rester sur
la question du calendrier sur ce qui
s'est passé P la présidence française de
l'Union européenne qu'il peut y avoir
mais pardon de m'en faire l'interprète
de volets ou deux angles dans votre
question est-ce que la France a porté la
question du fra de ferroviaire comme une
priorité je n'étais pas en charge des
réunions des ministres des Transports
mais oui je crois que dans la réunion
des ministres tenu par mon prédécesseur
à Toulouse la question de la
décarbonation la question du Fred
ferroviaèire a été évoqué ça fait partie
des sujets sur laquelle réul sur
lesquels pardon régulièrement la France
demande une stratégie européenne un plan
d'investissement européen et il y a un
lien très direct c'est le plan de
relance dans le cadre du plan de relance
nous avons fait comme d'autres pays mais
je crois pas la majorité le choix
d'avoir un élément un élément
ferroviaire un élément de soutien au
frais de ferroviare et ce plan a été
vous le savez en partie financé par les
aides européennes et soumis d'ailleurs à
la discussion de la Commission
européenne et de nos partenaires
européens dans la présidence française
de l'Union européenne cela n'a pas été
peut-être que c'était aussi sous-jacent
dans votre question en tout cas je me
permets de le préciser un handicap pour
la France autrement dit on ne met pas
son mouchoir dans sa poche pour discuter
ou défendre ses intérêts ou faire valoir
ses arguments pendant les 6 mois on
assure la présidence du Conseil de
l'Union européenne donc l'ensemble des
dossiers qui concernent les intérêts de
la France dont celui du fret ferroviaire
ont été évidemment défendus continuent
j'étais un peu éloigné mais par le
secrétaire d'État aux Affaires
européennes que j'étais par le ministre
des Transports de l'époque pendant cette
période je n'ai pas l'agenda de mon Pr
cur mais je suis certain que des
discussions on continué à avoir lieu à
ce moment-là avec la Commission
européenne sans si je puis dire ainsi
lever le stylo ou remaller nos arguments
sur la viabilité pérenne
oui je le crois profondément et
d'ailleurs on le voit la Commission
européenne est particulièrement
vigilante et exigeante dans ces analyses
de ce qu'on appelle l'investissement
avisé ou la viabilité économique et donc
si on fait ce scénario en posant les
lignes rouges en pensant qu'il permettra
de lever le risque existentiel et
juridique ce sera de toute façon soumis
à une décision de la Commission
européenne qui est particulièrement
stricte en général plus stricte que nos
propres analyses dans le maintien ou
l'existence d'une viabilité économique
pour l'opérateur qui est au cœur de la
procédure et donc autrement dit la
Commission ne validerait pas une
solution de discontinuité si elle ne
pensait pas que l'opérateur était viable
alors évidemment la perspective n'est
jamais garanti mais l'analyse est faite
à cet égard et je pense oui en effet
qu'avec la gestion capacitaire avec le
plan d'investissement et les a à
l'exploitation combiné nous avons de
quoi puisque la situation s'apprécie de
manière statique et dynamique dans la
décennie qui vient rendre le frais de
ferroviaire en général plus attractif et
augmenter la part modale et en
particulier un opérateur de frais de
ferroviaire public centré sur la gestion
capacitaire viable et attractif je le
crois profondément et cette analyse sera
de toute façon formulé aussi par les
autorités européennes sur
le le risque et le calendrier euh
oui je maintiens je prense profondément
qu'il y a
urgence vous avez dit d'autres pays ont
vécu subi de longues procédures d'abord
quand on discute tard et quand on
obtient un accord potentiel tard
l'expérience montre pas de certitude
absolue que les solutions de
discontinuité si c'est ça une finé qu'il
faut faire sont plus dur et plus brutal
il y a le précédent dit à l'Italia
plutôt sur mode de transport
aérien c'est 50 % de
discontinuité je le dis aussi parce que
l'idée c'est pas de négocier à n'importe
quelle condition avec n'importe quel
résultat c'est d'avoir je rappelais les
chiffres tout à l'heure 90 % de l'emploi
qui reste dans la structure ferroviaire
publique 80 % l'activité vous avez parlé
de 23 flux qui doivent en effet dans ce
cadrelà être cédés j'ai lu sacrifier pas
sacrifier dans le sens où on pas
disparaître céder à d'autres opérateurs
on espère bien qu'ils vont rester
évidemment dans le domaine du fret
ferroviaire mais ce sont des solutions
de discontinuité si elles se mettent
effectivement en place qui sont bien
moindres en terme de réduction de volume
de réduction de voilure que ce qu'on a
observé dans beaucoup d'autres cas et
donc nous avons fixé des intérêts des
lignes rouges qui sont extrêmement
claires je le maintiens en effet fait
nous sommes dans un moment et les
comparaisons européennes trouvent un
moment leur limite où dans notre pays la
stratégie ferroviaire frit de
ferroviaire pardon dernier endate date
de fin 2021 le dernier vote du Parlement
date de l'été 2021 avec la loi climat
résilience où nous avons no premiers
résultat en 2021 2022 d'inversion de la
courbe et de remontée de la part modale
du frais de ferroviaire donc je pense
que dans ce contexte làà et en
l'accompagnant d'un plan
d'investissement ce que n'ont pas fait
d'autres pays donc comparonsnous vers le
haut oui je pense qu'il est préférable
c'est mon sentiment ma conviction
profonde de donner une visibilité à
rapide à Fret SNCF ou à l'opérateur de
fret ferroviaires public sur le plan
social sur le plan écologique et sur le
plan industriel et de dire rapidement au
clients vous avez une perspective dans
le domaine du fra de ferroviaire et avec
un opérateur de Fra de ferroviaire
public qui prendra la succession de frit
SNCF je dis pas que c'est à 3 jours près
mais il est clair qu'il y a urgence pour
cela et que c'est ressenti dit ils le
lont devant votre commission par les
chargeurs y y a-t-il des
garanties poser cette question légitime
de la part de la Commission européenne
je vous ferai une réponse politique mais
qui n'est pas politicienne et une
réponse juridique d'abord c'est aussi
pour ça que c'est important d'aller vite
les décisions formelles se prennent au
vu des solutions mises en place par
l'État qui est soumis la procédure
autrement dit c'est si on met en place
la discontinuité qu'on a la garantie
finale et la décision formelle
définitive de la Commission européenne
parce que j'entends
parfois vous avez qu'à obtenir le
blancin on met en place et puis on voit
ça marche dans l'autre sens sur le plan
juridique c'est à condition de faire un
certain nombre de transformations que
vous levez le risque que j'ai évoqué
évidemment et je ne serais pas allé on
m'a posé aussi la question pourquoi le
faire à ce moment-là pourquoi pas plutôt
pourquoi pas plus tard je ne serais pas
allé moi-même rencontrer les salariés
rencontrer les syndicats écrire à l'
entreprise et je tiens évidemment à
votre disposition l'ensemble des
courriers mais ils sont en partie dans
les dossiers d'instance représentative
du personnel tel que prévoit la loi je
n'aurais pas donner à l'entreprise au
salariier de l'entreprise un certain de
garantie d'effort et de garantie si je
n'avais pas une certitude raisonnable
pardon de le dire
ainsi que la Commission européenne et
nous pouvons atterrir si je peux dire
sur cet équilibre là et je tiens
évidemment il y a eu des échanges je
l'ai dit mon agenda public je peux vous
le Rec iqué précisément si rendez-vous
depuis l'été 2022 avec la
vice-présidente vesttiger chargé de la
concurrence un certain nombre d'échanges
formels écrit et donc je tiens
évidemment à la disposition si vous le
souhaitez tel que d'ailleurs c'est prévu
par mon serment et par la loi et c'est
bien normal l'ensemble des échanges qui
se sont tenus mais dont je crois le
meilleur résumé en toute transparence ou
le meilleur non pas résumé la meilleure
liste est fourni dans le courrier que
j'ai moi-même adressé sur cette base au
président directeur général de la SNCF
Jean-Pierre farandou en date dire une
bêtises du 24 mai ou du 23 mai
2023 sur les
impacts modo si je peux dire les
impacts le but c'est évidemment que tout
ce qui sera cédé je dis pas que c'est
une bonne nouvelle je dis que c'est cet
équilibre que j'assume tout ce qui sera
cédé notamment les 23 flux le but c'est
que ça reste je peux pas le garantir
parce que c'est un combat aussi ça reste
dans le domaine du fret ferroviaire pas
dans le domaine de fr SNCF dans le
domaine du FR ferroviaire et là aussi
plus rapidement on donne de la
visibilité plus rapidement ces flux ces
activités sont connues cédé plus il y a
de chance que c'est un autre opérateur
ferroviaire qui le récupère ce qui est
mieux que d'avoir un opérateur de fret
non
ferroviaire et je reviens sur la
question du calandrier mais vous m'avez
déjà entendu le dire plusieurs fois donc
je serai bref c'est que là aussi
l'impact global va dépendre de nos
efforts d'accompagnement et
d'investissement d'où le plan et de la
rapidité avec laquelle on donne cette
visibilité à un nouvel opérateur de
frais de ferroviaire public pour la
gestion capacitaire donc pardon de
pasêtre plus précis dans les impacts
mais il est clair que les impact
s'apprécie si je peux dire de manière
dynamique moins on a d'incertitude plus
vite on a une solution stabilisée une
organisation
claire plus on a de chance de garder
cette activité dans le domaine du frais
de ferroviaire public et du frais de
ferroviaire tout court et je le dis
aussi l'idée c'est pas simplement de
stabiliser la part modale de toute façon
c'est une obligation fixée par le
Parlement et par la loi c'est
d'atteindre les 18 % et pour cela de
mettre en œuvre l'ensemble des mesures
dont le plan renforcé que j'ai indiqué
je crois vous avoir répondu monsieur le
rapporteur sur les trains mutualisés y
a-t-il une viabilité économique
peut-être un dernier point dans
l'analyse de la Commission européenne
telle qu'elle ressort de la lettre
d'ouverture de la procédure du 18
janvier 2023 puisque je ne l'ai
peut-être pas dit assez en détail je
crois que vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président l'investigation la procédure
porte sur longue période qui remonte à
2007 qui va jusqu'à 2019 mais qui qui
principalement porte sur la première
décennie en terme de de masse d'aide si
je peux dire
euh nous avons parfois des différences
d'interprétation avec la Commission
européenne mais ce qui a été fait
notamment dans la loi sur le nouveau
pacte ferroviaire est neutre si je peux
dire l'appréciation de la commission
c'està-dire l'organisation et le
transfert de dettes qui a été opéré à
cette époque-là n'est pas reproché par
la Commission européenne une autre
organisation n'aura pas empêché
l'enquête et je le redis de toute façon
l'investigation et l'immense majorité
des sommes plus de 5 milliards ur au
total sont évalués investigué au titre
d'une période qui commence en 2007 et
qui va jusqu'à
2017 merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre de ces
réponses Monsieur Jean-Marc zuli
souhaitait poser une question et ensuite
monsieur le député Thomas porte monsieur
le Président vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président pardonnez-moi
monsieur le Président est-ce que vous
pouvez simplement nous présiser les
modalités pour poser des questions si on
est limité en temps ou pas
on a très exactement jusqu'à 16h30
puisque monsieur le ministre a accepté
de nous accorder 2h et on le remercie
puisque cette audition est plus longue
que les autres vous avez la parole
néanmoins pour que tout le monde puisse
la parole puisse circuler librement on
est tous invités à faire des questions
assez assez très bien le message est
passé merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur chers collègues
merci monsieur le ministre de prendre le
temps de venir devant cette commission
d'enquête saluer l'action que nous avons
porté ensemble en particulier avec le
maire de Miramas pour faire de cette
gare de triage de
Miramas une priorité et que des
investissements arrivent et arrivent
vite vous l'avez rappelé plusieurs
questions se posent et je serai succin
première question concernant l'évolution
des tarifs des péages ferroviaires
est-ce que vous pourriez nous partager
encore une fois de manière très
synthétique mais comment est-ce que ces
péages ferroviaires ont évolué euh au
sujet du fraed ferroviaire notamment
dans la période
200727 le deuxème sujet c'est sur cette
même période l'évolution de la part
modale puisque aujourd'hui nous avons
cette volonté je l'ai porté dans la loi
d'orientation des mobilités de doubler
la part modale de 9 à 18 % on a ajouté
cette date lors de la loi climat
résilience vous l'avez rappelé quelle
est l'évolution de cette part modale 3è
question comment peut-on expliquer que
la France est persisté avec ces aides
connaissant le risque au niveau européen
comment vous l'interpréter et comment
aujourd'hui on peut tout simplement
éviter que dans l'avenir nous nous
rencontrions ce même type de problème et
enfin s'agissant de la des décisions de
cette cette Commission européenne
comment s'assurer que l'Europort
modal ne soit pas vers la route et que
nous perdions l'ambition que nous avons
porté notamment lors de cette loi climat
résilience je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président zoulezy
quelques points en réponse à vos
interrogations celle du pH est
essentielle euh puisque de manière
générale nous le savons dans le système
ferroviaire français c'est un point de
faiblesse ou de vigilance nous avons et
c'est vrai pour le fret comme c'est vrai
pour le reste du système ferrovire
d'ailleurs les Pag parmi les plus élevés
d'Europe c'est exact je ne reviens pas
sur la question du trafic voyageur qui
est spécifique qui n'est pas l'objet de
notre débat mais sur la question du fret
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous avons mis en place pour tous les
opérateurs de fret ferroviaire
puisquévidemment c'est une mesure
transversale mais ça bénéficie largement
à Fret SNCF des aides au péage et dans
le paquet d'aide à l'ex exploitation que
j'évoquais il y a évidemment deux
grandes catégories qui sont les aides au
wagons isolés les aides au péage et pour
être tout à fait précis dans l'effort
que nous faisons pour l'avenir ce que
j'ai annoncé au printemps 2023 pour la
décennie qui vient en tout cas jusqu'à
2030 nous maintenons et nous pérénisons
les aides au péag au niveau post- plan
de
relance et nous augmentons encore les
aides au wagons isolés sans ces aides au
péage nous aurions sans doute une
réduction très forte de la part modale
du fret et une BAE compétitivité du
frais de ferroviaire par rapport aux
autres modes de transport de
marchandises l'estimation c'est une
étude du Conseil Général du
développement durable qui date
maintenant de de 2015 c'est que sans les
mesures d'aide au péage c'est 150 %
d'augmentation du phéage que nous
aurions donc oui les phéag sont élevés
sont compensés par ce mécanisme d'aide
au phage ce mécanisme nous le pérénisons
pour l'ensemble des opérateurs de fraes
ferroviair dans les années qui viennent
et je le rappelle nous renforçons en
même temps que nous pérénisons les aides
aux wagons isolés également sur la part
modale je l'ai dit hein c'est très
important c'est vraiment la fin de la
décennie 90 début des années 2000 que la
chute a été la plus spectaculaire nous
avions à peu près 20 % de part du Fred
ferroviaire dans le fret total au début
de la décennie
1990 nous avons chuté jusqu'au début des
années 2000 et c'est à peu près en 2006
que c'est stabilisé à un point bas qui
était autour de 10 %. et c'est resté bon
en Malan assez stable autour de ces 10 %
jusqu'à très récemment où notamment
depuis le réinvestissement permis par le
plan de relance nous avons réussi à
faire
réaugmenter de manière encore modérée il
faut être très honnête autour de 11 %
mais la part modale du fret et je l'ai
dit le trafic est le plus élevé depuis
en volume depuis 2015 la part modale est
la plus élevée depuis
2017 et l'autre objectif et bien il est
très ambitieux il a été fixé par le
Parlement de doubler cette part modale
par rapport à la référence qui a été
prise au moment de la loi climat
résilience 9 % cétait un peu un point
bas une estimation basse jusqu'à 18 % en
euh comment éviter la question enfin
comment expliquer la FO la persistance
des aides et la sécurité des aides qui
existent sur la persistance des aides je
ne peux pas interpréter toutes les
décisions qui ont été prises ces
dernières années ce que je peux dire
c'est qu'il y a eu des aides à
l'exploitation au fonctionnements qui
ont été successivement mis en place ce
qui montre bien d'ailleurs que le sujet
n'était pas tellement une forme
d'abandon par l'État on va le dire à
l'inverse de l'opérateur Fred SNCF
puisqu'il était pas seul mais notamment
très soutenu ce qui n'a pas permis en
soit d'augmenter la part modale donc
cétait bien que c'était pas le seul
sujet estce qui je ne peux pas évaluer
le risque juridique qui était pris à
l'époque nous a conduit aussi à
accumuler une situation jugée je suis
prudent par la procédure est en cours
illégale aujourd'hui par la Commission
européenne sur plus de 10 ans euh je le
redis euh les dernières aides qui ont
été mise en place par mes deux
prédécesseurs et notamment au moment du
plan de relance ont été
notifiés validé par la commission
européenne et donc le cadre juridique
dans lequel nous nous inscrivons
aujourd'hui celui que j'ai indiqué des
300 millions devenant 330 millions d'EOS
par an de soutien à l'explloitation est
un cadre validé de toute façon il fallir
le renotifier c'est la procédure
européenne et donc au cours de l'an 2024
nous n renotifierons pour l'avenir mais
comme nous avons en place comme nous
mettons en place les mêmes types d'Aid
que Cell qui existent depuis le plan de
relance au
moins validé je n'ai pas beaucoup de
doute sur la validation par la
Commission européenne même si nous
augmentons le niveau d'A mais nous n'en
changeons pas la nature donc je le dis
parce que c'est une question légitime
que on m'a posé que ne rejouons pas le
match du passé si je peux dire oui on a
aujourd'hui un cadre d'aide assumé je le
dis aussi l'Europe n'interdit pas les
aides au frais de ferroviair et
n'interdit pas d'avoir un opérateur de
frais de ferroviaire public c'est très
importantut pas qu'on fasse ce mauvais
procès je les désaccord sur la procédure
actuelle il y a pas d'interdiction de
principe des aides il faut les notifier
intégralement qu'elles soi validées
qu'ell s'incrivent dans le cadre
autorisé et celles qui sont aujourd'hui
en place ont été validées seront
renotifiés dans les prochains mois je
crois que je réponds monsieur le
Président à vos
questions merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre euh on peut même ajouter
puisque vous évoquiez le le déclin de la
part modale comme on l'a relevé hier que
entre 1968 et 1994 donc avant la période
que vous évoqué le la part modale du fra
de ferroviaire a été divisé par 3 en
France et à l'époque il y avait un seul
opérateur qui était présent sur le sur
le marché CEI aussi pour compléter nos
analyses et en effet comme vous le
disiez le redressement de 2021- 20022
est le premier en par modal depuis des
décennies mais c'est aussi les deux
premiers exercices sur lesquels fr SNCF
n'est pas déficitaire pour la première
fois de depuis des décennies là aussi i
je voulais justement préciser ce point
monsieur le Président puce que je crois
que ça va bien avec la question de la
part mododale quand on regarde non
seulement les par modales mais la
situation les résultat d'exploitation de
fr SNCF donne quelques chiffres il était
de moins de 100 millions en 2001 de Mo-
300 millions en 2002 donc il se dégrade
avant la libéralisation de Mo- 400
millions en 2003 de - 325 millions en
et puisque nous parlions de la réforme
notamment la visibilité ou de la
viabilité monsieur le rapporteur c'est
bien non pas par l'opération du
Saint-Esprit mais par des aides
notifiées et par la réorganisation les
efforts portés par les salariés le frit
SNCF depuis la réforme de 2020 que nous
avons en 212 un résultat qui est
redevenu positif et une part modale qui
augmente et donc je le dis nous avons
aussi c'est la raison pour laquelle je
suis confiant pour l'avenir nous
réorganisons les choses non pas de gêé
de cœur et ça serait dispensé et nous
réorganisons les choses dans un contexte
où l'opérateur de frais de ferroviaire
public à des clients à un résultat
positif et s'est transformé donc il
n'est pas du tout dans la même situation
que si on était il y a 15 ou 20 ans où
soyons très clair il n'avait que très
peu de perspective de marché dans la
situation
d'alors merci Monsieur le Ministre on a
déjà six collègues qui veut poser qui
veulent poser des questions donc on
prendra d'abord les la question de
Monsieur Thomas porte et et celle
peut-être à la suite de Madame Mireille
clapau merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie d'être là pour
pour répondre à vre question sur un
sujet qui est qui est majeur je vais
être rapide j'ai j'ai trois questions
donc vous nous expliquez qu'il y a une
ambition de report modal euh de passer
de la part modale de la développé de 9 à
18 % ce qui est une ambition que tout le
monde partage moi j'aimerais savoir
comment on fait alors que le plan de
discontinuité il va supprimer 263
conducteurs à Fred SNCF donc vous
ambitionnez de passer à 9 à à 18 % en
liquidant une parie des conducteurs de
frit SNCF aujourd'hui donc c'estàd vous
proposez de faire plus avec moins de
moyens pour l'opérateur public
historique sur la question du de des du
risque de transfert vers la route des 23
euh flux que que vous avez en tout cas
négocié le fait qu'elle soit cédée
qu'elle ne soit plus dans le périmètre
de de fret SNCF donc vous pouvez nous
confirmer que vous avez des garanties
que ces 23 flux vont rester sur le rail
euh au lendemain de la procédure ou pas
où est-ce qu'il y a des risques qu'il
partent sur la route parce que c'est ça
le danger qui pèse sur ces futurs flux
et notamment moi je je vous pose une
question c'est sur un sujet sur lequel
j'ai beaucoup travaillé est-ce que vous
avez euh de la visibilité sur le train
perpin rangis qui est un un sujet
emblématique et et important et enfin la
la trisème question vous avez pas
répondu est-ce que quelle est la
responsabilité de la réforme du
ferroviaire qui avait été largement
combattu à l'époque sur la
transformation de Fred SNCF en société
anonyme notamment le fait qu'il fallait
investir dedans pour la relancer ce qui
est aujourd'hui un des griefs de la
Commission européenne dans l'enquête qui
est déclenchée donc voilà c'est les les
trois questions que j'ai à vous poser et
peut-être une dernière un peu plus
piquante puisque j'entends ici que
l'ouverture à à la concurrence et la
libéralisation finalement ne serait pas
un élément qui aurait détruit le fret de
ferroviaire et que ce n'est pas un
problème écoutez moi quand je vois les
chiffres de fret SNCF o on est passé de
20000 cheminau à moins de 5000 où on a
le nombre de de triage qui a diminué le
nombre de terminaux combinés qui a été
divisé par deux le nombre
d'embranchements temporair qui a qui a
quasiment été diminué par 5 en tout cas
dans la possibilité de les utiliser euh
aujourd'hui est-ce que pour vous il y a
pas quand même une chose c'est que la
libéralisation elle a eu un impact sur
le transport ferroviaire public en
France est-ce que il faudrait pas faire
différemment puisque on a depuis des
années l'expérience de la libéralisation
et on voit que ça n'a pas marché on voit
que ça a eu un impact négatif sur le
transport de marchandis sur les
conditions sociales des salar AR sur
notre réseau ferré donc est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas le moment de
prendre une autre pente celui d'un
transport public ferroviaire qui soit
vraiment important et qui soit sorti des
logiques de marché mais compte tenu
comme je le disais du nombre de
questions on va prendre tout de suite
également la question de Miry clapau
monsieur le ministre si vous en êtes
d'accord et vous répondrez à ces deux
questions ensuite on prendra par grape
de deux
questions merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur monsieur le
ministre je salue l'ambition de votre
ministère c'est notre ambition à tousin
de soutenir le frais ferroviaire public
alors moi je voudrais dire d'abord que
la vraie concurrence elle est pas entre
deux opérateurs ferroviaire mais quand
on est un chargeur là je fais référence
à des vies antérieures professionnelles
que j'ai eu quand on a des marchandises
à transporter on ne choisit pas entre
deux opérateurs ferroviaires mais on
choisit entre le fer et la route
principalement bon j'aimerais pouvoir
parler du du fluvial mais je je crois
que c'est pas trop d'actualité alors moi
je voudrais vous interroger sur le fond
du problème qui me semble être la
qualité de service de la SNCF parce que
pour qu'un chargeur préfère le train au
camion il faut qu'il soit sûr de la
ponctualité donc du respect des
engagements que le matériel est adapté
que le service est associé on sait que
de plus en plus les conducteurs de
camion ils déchargent les les
marchandises à l'arrivée il y a aussi la
question du niveau de prix et je ne
pense pas en posant cette question
m'éloigner du sujet parce que je pense
que c'est lié aux investissements les
investissements ce n'est pas que du rail
et du matériel roulant c'est aussi aussi
du numérique des ressources humaines
peut-être une stratégie commerciale donc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quelle
est l'ambition et quelles sont les
moyens donnés à ces objectifs
merci vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
député madame la députée je vais essayer
de quelques liens d'ailleurs entre la
fin de vos deux interventions donc je
essayer d'y répondre complètement mais
peut-être en faisant quelques quelques
mutualisations si je pe pu dire ainsi
Monsieur le Député
porte sur les effectifs pour être précis
ce qui est en jeu c'est environ vous
avez parlé des conducteurs c'est un peu
plus large que cela puisque c'est
l'essentiel de l'activité concerné mais
c'est pas avoir moins d'agents dont les
conducteurs dans le système de frais de
ferroviaire c'est ça je l'ai dit environ
10 % des emploi de ce qui est
aujourd'hui l'opérateur fright SNCF qui
ne seront plus dans le nouvel opérateur
ferroviaire public nomination n'existe
pas encore euh donc on fait pas avec
moins on fait avec des conducteurs et
des agences et 20036 conducteurs et à
peu près 400 agents au total qui doivent
rester dans le système du fra de
ferroviaire qui ont peut-être en effet
chez d'autres opérateurs et s'il ne
trouvent pas de solution c'est
l'engagement social que j'ai pris qui
puisse rester dans le groupe SNCF et
revenir à l'activité de frit dont nous
espérons par les investissements que
nous menons qu'elle se redéveloppera
notamment la gestion capacitaire donc il
s'agit pas
de supprimer dans l'ensemble des
opérateurs de fretes ferroviair des
effectifs il s'agit pas de faire moins
avec de faire plus avec moi l'idée c'est
exactement ce que dit Madame madame les
député clapau c'est que l'ensemble de
ces compétences de ces personnels
restent dans le système ferroviaire ils
sont peut-être chez un autre opérateur
ça c'est possible mais qui doit être un
opérateur de frais de ferroviaire donc
vous disz est-ce que c'est compatible
avec l'ambition de développement du fret
de ferroviaire oui bien sûr parce que le
but c'est de d'éviter le report modal
vers la route le but c'est d'éviter le
report modal vers des camions et quelle
est la meilleure façon d'éviter le
report modal vers des camions je
l'assume et je le pense profondément
c'est évidemment d'investir et de
soutenir en évitant d'avoir le même
problème dans 5 an donc avec des aides
légales investissement
exploitation mais c'est aussi d'aller
vite pour que un chargeur ne se disent
pas est-ce que dans 6 mois dans 9 mois
dans 18 mois j'ai encore une entreprise
prise de Fra ferroviaire qui me permet
le transport qu'on lui dise vite oui
vous avez un opérateur de transport
ferroviaire qui peut être l'opérateur
succédant à frit SNCF selon les cas ou
un autre donc on ne supprime pas du
système de frait de ferroviaire 400
agents et je pense même qu'il faut aller
plus loin il y aura des garanties qui
seront précises pour que dans certains
cas il puisse y avoir une sous-traitance
d'un opérateur à l'opérateur ferroviaire
public donc l'idée ce n'est pas d'avoir
moins d'acteurs et moins d'agents du
système ferroviaire du système de frais
de ferroviaire c'est quand même très
important et évidemment d'assurer pour
les personnels statutairees par
définition mais aussi pour les personnel
contractuel c'est environ 10 % des
effectif aujourd'hui une garantie totale
d'emploi au sein du groupe à chaque fois
qu'il le souhaite ou qu'il y en a besoin
j'espère êre plus précis possible mais
c'est très important donc on n'est pas
en train d'avoir moins de gens dans le
système de frais de ferroviaire et plus
d'ambition en même temps loin de là sur
les flux qui va faire partie des à peu
près 20 % d'activité CD j'insiste sur le
fait fait que même si je l'ai dit
préférait qu'on s'en dispense évidemment
par rapport à des solutions de procédure
européennes à peu près équivalente dans
des le domaine des transports et la
logistique une discontinuité
habituellement j'aime pas beaucoup cette
expression enfin regardons les cas
précédents c'est environ 50 % de
réduction du volume on sera évidemment
pas du tout dans cet ordre de grandeur
c'est très important et donc l'idée
c'est justement que pour ces flux pour
ces activités là qui seront transféré à
d'autres opérateurs il y ait là aussi un
calendrier rapide non pas pour être
brutalisant mais pour donner une
perspective rapide et qu'on reste là
encore dans le mode de transport frait
de ferroviaire et qu'on ne remette pas
du train sur du camion je l'ai dit dans
les trois axes que je défends il y a
l'emploi il y a l'avoir un opérateur de
frais de ferroviaire public et il y a
évidemment l'exigence écologique qui est
au bornes du système de ne pas
transférer du train vers le camion vers
la route et donc euh les choses ne sont
pas faites d'ailleurs c'est pas moi qui
vais le faire mais les sessions ou les
transferts doivent se faire rapidement
pour que ce soit d'autres opérateurs de
fretes ferroviair et pas d'autres
opérateur de fret dans d'autres modes de
transport qui récupèr cette
activité pour être le plus précis
possible dans ce cadre-là il y a un cas
emblématique je sais votre attachement à
ce train le train des primeurs comme on
l'appelle le perpignant ringis là aussi
on a eu l'occasion d'en discuter je veux
quand même être précis évidemment ce
train il est soutenu il ser il est
soutenu par l'État il continuera à
soutenu par l'État et d'ailleurs preuve
que on reste dans un cadre de régulation
publique il a besoin de subvention pour
fonctionner mais j'ai aucun problème
avec ça il faut l'assumer parce que il
rend des services écologiques essentiels
bon donc on assume de faire fonctionner
notre système ferroviaire avec des
subventions y compris le frit y compris
quand c'est un opérateur qui n'est pas
forcément frit SNCF le train des
primimeurs pour en faire l'historique en
deux mots c'est nous je pas ministre des
Transports mais la majorité actuelle le
gouvernement de Jean Castex qui l'a
relancé sinon il existerait plus en
mettant 12 millions d'euros sur la table
pour subventionner son activité parce
qu'il est important et parce qu'il est
aussi symbolique et emblématique
assumons-le et de toute façon c'est un
système qui fonctionne par appel à
manifestation d'intérêt pardon pour la
les termes technique régulier on devait
le faire en 2025 de mémoire c'était
prévu comme ça on le fera en 2024 compte
tenu de la situation nouvelle mais je
l'ai dit je m'y suis engagé et je l'ai
même prouvé par un appel à manifestation
d'intérêt que j'ai relancé que mon
ministère a lancé je crois la fin du
mois d'août nous faisons appel à un
opérateur avec subvention d'État pour
que le train des primeurs continue à
circuler et donc oui le train des
primeurs avec des subventions publiques
légales continuera à fonctionner dans
les années qui viennent je ne sais pas
qui en sera l'opérateur c'est l'objet de
l'appelle à manifestation d'intérêt donc
on peut débattre de trouver que c'est
une mauvaise chose que ça soit tel ou
tel opérateur on verra l'issue de la
procédure mais en tout cas la garantie
que je prends devant vous c'est que ce
train continuera à circuler nous l'avons
relancé c'est pas pour l'abandonner il a
connu des difficultés en début d'année
une technique c'était un desraillement à
Carcassonne l'autre ils ont le
franchement social qui est les
mouvements de grève je la respecte mais
c'est un fait nous avons relancé dès le
mois de mai et il continuera à
fonctionner avec le soutien de l'État
par cet appel à manifestation d'intérêt
sur la réforme de 2018 la loi
ferroviaire
euh là aussi soyons très précis je pense
son premier impact sur le fret en tout
cas ça a été les chiffres le démontrent
de remettre en situation de viabilité
économique Fred SNCF la réforme de 2018-
20020 n'est pas étrangère au résultats
positifs fa les consolider positifs que
nous connaissons je les ai rappelé le
président Valence les a rappelé de fr
SNCF et de la partmodale du Fred par
conséquent donc le premier impact de la
réforme sur ce sujet c'est que ça nous a
fait passer une situation où chaque
année l'opérateur était en déficit avant
la libéralisation j'insiste avant la
libéralisation à une situation où il ne
l'est plus et on le doit évidemment aux
agents de la SNCF et de fr SNCF qui ont
fait des efforts considérables vous le
savez comme moi je le sais mais qui pte
leur fruit quand on fait des efforts vin
c'est un peu frustrant quand on fait des
efforts qui portent leur fruit pour
l'activité
économique on le voit mais c'est aussi
un effet de cette réorganisation et de
cette réform ensuite il y a un point
deux points techniques pour tout à fait
précis il y a qu' a eu vous le savez un
transfert de dette de la de l'unité à la
SA ça fait partie des examens ou des
grifs qui sont examinés par la
commission européenne mais ça ne change
pas la situation économique et
l'appréciation globale que porte la
Commission et il y a un point deuxième
point technique précis qui est dans la
lettre et dans dans l'examen pardon
l'investigation de la commission c'est
que sur les 5,3 milliards d'aides qui
sont reproché je le dis comme ça il y a
très précisément 160 70 millions d'euros
qui date de l'après 2017 je vous dis
tout c'est dans façon dans le domaine
public donc c'est une toute petite
partie si on avait pas ce problème de
170 millions d'euros don nous contestons
l'illégalité mais on aurait quand même
5,1 milliards
j'arrondis qui serait en jeu donc le
sujet n'est pas là le sujet c'est est-ce
que oui ou non on attend et est-ce que
oui ou non on est capable le cas échéant
de rembourser 5 ou 5,3 milliards d'euros
c'est ça le sujet et comment on répond à
cette menace voilà donc je vous partage
exactement les contenus du calendrier
que la Commission européenne a mis dans
sa procédure ouverte en janvier dernier
sur la libéralisation pas tout à fait
l'objet mais enfin vous posz la question
on peut être pour ou contre la
libéralisation du Fred ça a été un débat
européen moi je pas je vais pas dire
c'est la faute à Bruxelles la France
c'estes gouvernements de l'époque qui
ont été une majorité successive
d'ailleurs on participé à la discussion
et on accepté ce que je constate
simplement c'est un la situation était
très dégradé avant la libéralisation je
crois qu'on peut convenir de ce point
donc en tout cas même si vous pensez que
la libéralisation un mauvais effet c'est
pas la libéralisation l'ouverture la
concurrence qui a créé une situation où
Fred SNCF ce qui est devenu frit SNCF
était en situation de déficite c'était
bien avant et le recul massif de la part
modale on l'a rappelé c'était bien avant
bon donc en tout cas c'est pas du tout
le facteur déclencheur entendons-nous au
moins sur ce point deux quand je regarde
la situation des autres pays européens
soumis aux mêmes règles il y en a qui
ont une part du Fred qui n'a pas
décroché qui est même augmenté il y en a
ça dépend de beaucoup de facteurs he une
structure industrielle aussi parfois
l'Allemagne a une tradition de Fra de
ferroviaire plus grande que la nôtre
peut-être ils ont mieux investi dans les
infrastructures ils ont aussi une
industrie qui a moins reculé que la
nôtre soyons clair ça permet d'avoir
évidemment plus d'activité économique
pour le frit de
ferroviaire la libéralisation nous
laisse avec un paysage européen très
diversifié en terme de paire modale du
fret avec le même cadre légal donc à
tout le moins faut avoir un débat sur la
libéralisation qui nous occuperait un
long moment mais accordons-nous sur le
fait que les problèmes ont commencé
avant bien avant qui se sont d'ailleurs
pas ils nont pas augmenté après puisque
j'ai dit la part modale du fret est
stable depuis 2006près elle remonte
maintenant à cadre légal identique donc
c'est possible et que d'autres pays ont
fait mieux que nous avec moins d'aide
d'ailleurs donc en tout cas c'est pas le
montant du chèque qui fait
euh la viabilité du
fret donc j'assume totalement que c'est
un secteur qui doit être soutenu par des
subventions dans un cadre sécurisé
monsieur Zoui à juste titre me l'a
demandé que nous le faisons et que nous
le renforçons et l'effort
d'investissement j'iniste parce que je
crois que c'est ça la vraie différence
est inédit en ce moment et pour les
années qui viennent notamment dans not
triage madame la clapo vous posez la
question de qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on
recours si je je résume ou j'interprète
un peu librement qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'on recours ou pas au frais de
ferroviaire et à tel ou tel opérateur
oui c'est vrai alors je ne suis pas
chargeur je n'ai pas travill dans
ce secteur mais on entend un certain
nombre de critiques pas seulement à
l'égard de tel ou tel opérateur don
frncf sur la qualité de service sur la
fiabilité des circulations et cetera je
vais être très honnête ça existe sans
doute mais ce qui m'intéresse en tant
que responsable public c'est qu'est-ce
que nous nous pouvons faire de mieux et
je crois qu'il y a deux choses qu'on
peut faire mieux c'est d'abord même si
évidemment trafic voyageur est important
ne pas toujours privilégier dans nos
sillons même quand a des mouvements
sociaux des aditations de plan de
transport et cetera le voyageur au fret
parce que sinon on n'est pas cohérent
avec l'ambition qu'on porte sur le fret
petit 1 et grand 2 si je peux dire
investir dans nos infrastructures les
agents font un travail formidable avec
une infrastructure
dégradée vous allez je leur dis j'ai été
extrêmement frappé sans être un expert
technique vous allez à voi vous allez à
Miramas vous allez au Bourget euh on
n'est pas à la hauteur d'investissement
moderne et c'est pas c'est un ont de
longue période et donc c'est pour ça que
je crois que l'effort de financement on
doit le faire porter plus encore que sur
les exploitation sur l'investissement et
la remise à niveau de nos gardes de
triage tout particulièrement c'est ça
qui fera la qualité de service à la fin
et le fait qu'on reste dans le domaine
ferroviaire plutôt que d'aller vers la
route et puis pardon de jeter ce pavé
dans la mar c'est quelques grandes
infrastructure ferroviaire de
fret je pense à un terminal comme
cherbour muger dans lequel nous
investissons avec une entreprise
française qui produit des wagons l'or
euh monsieur le député euh je pense au
lyonturin je n'ouvre pas ce débat mais
ça fait partie des sujets et donc nous
avons aussi besoin de lignes de frais de
ferroviaire qui font que il y a une
activité économique notamment pour
l'oppérateur ferroviare public lon Turin
pour lequel votre lointain prédécesseur
Jean-Claude guessau a pldé avec beaucoup
de force ici devant la commission
d'enquête hier on prend deux questions
tout de suite l'une de Monsieur Vincent
thébau monsieur le député du barrain et
l'autre de Madame Marie Guy député du de
haute Garon qui est en visioconférence
monsieur le député du du barrain oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
euh un point que je voudrais évoquer
vous avez commencé à évoquer aussi
effectivement c'est le sujet des
infrastructures qui est absolument
nécessaire effectivement au-delà de de
la problématique actuelle pour pouvoir
développer rapidement et et dans les
années à venir le le frais de
ferroviaire ma question va se poser plus
particulèrement sur sujet des autoroutes
ferroviaires puisqueen fait nous avons
deux aspects nous avons le wagon isolé
on a plutôt infrastructure qui nécessite
de faire du chargement vertical les
autoroutes ferroviaires qui sont une
véritable alternative notamment au
transit routier puisque là c'est des
semis qui partent sur des longues
distances comme nous le pouvons le vivre
nous dans la région en Alsace et dans la
région Grand Est notamment par des
transit qui vient des ports d'envers de
Rotterdam et qui vont vers le sud de de
la France ou de l'Europe et à cette
alnative là effectivement il faut qu'on
puisse proposer des autoroute
ferroviaire euh sur la question des
infrastructures justement par rapport à
les autoroutes aujourd'hui il y a deux
cultures ça ét un peu évoqué hier lors
deaudition de Monsieur janté c'est
efftivement la problématique des
gabarits aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
du gabarit GB gp400 pardon mais on sait
que ce gabarit là nécessiterait des
infrastructures des travaux
d'infrastructure assez conséquents
puisque les estimations globalement pour
faire des autoroutes ferroviaires
européennes on parle de 3,5 ou entre 3,5
et 4 milliards d'investissement et des
travaux qui s'écouleraient entre 20 et
30 ans ce qui est assez assez long et ce
qui va un peu en contre au sens de ce
nous voulons aller vite et après il y a
des solutions comme vous l'avez évoqué
des solutions qui qui marchent qui
existent notamment je pense à la
solution de l'or industrie que vous avez
que vous avez cité qui propose
effectivement l'avantage de faire des
chargements non pas verticaux mais
horizontaux et pour des coûts moindres
puisqueeffectivement il y aurait pas de
gros travaux à faire notamment sur les
sur les infrastructures horis
effectivement faire c'est les les les
quai de chargement et de déchargement
avec le gros avantage aussi de pouvoir
faire un chargement des chargements
rapides rapides des trains je voudrais
un peu évoquer ce sujet effectivement
per nous en parler un peu nous éclairer
aussi sur cette vision en TER
d'infrastructure qui est importante
effectivement dans le cadre du
développement ferroviaire et un dernier
petit une petite question complémentaire
si vous me permettez c'est notamment la
problématique des coûts de connexion
entre les entreprises et le réseau feré
j'ai par notamment dans ma cerco deux
entreprises logistique importante une
qui qui est bien connue qui s'appelle
for maché et une autre qui s'appelle
Jung tout les deux ont les rails qui
passent à moins de 100 m de l'entreprise
le coût de connexion au réseau annoncé
parncf est de 100 millions d'euros 10
millions d'euros alors que les railes
sont juste à côté et c'est vrai que
l'entreprise dis-moi à ce prix-l je ne
peux pas financer des des travaux de de
connexion et il y a eu le cas mais
j'avoue aussi c'est bien dans le passé
des cas où les entreprises dans le Nord
Alsace ont voulu faire financer
eux-mêmes la connexion et ils ont eu F
du SNCF réseau donc voilà si vous pouvez
nous en dire quelques mots sur ce sujet
là je vous en remercie merci monsieur le
député on prend la question de Madame
Hary madame la députée vous avez la
parole
bonjour Merci monsieur le Président
d'abord d'avoir organisé cette vision
suite à mon
entêtement sur le sujet qui permet du
coup à se députés puisque je les vois là
de par parciper et non seulement de voir
mais de
participer donc merci au service de
l'assemblée
de l'avoir fait en urgence donc monsieur
le ministre vous avez fait dans un votre
propos introductif de perspective
positive pour le fret les portant de 9 à
18 %chandise qui étent transporté par le
train et vous avez rappelé fort
justement que les opérateurs du fret
souhaitent que cela aille vite alors je
le rappelle il faut que ça aille vite
vite il faut que ce soit aussi décarboné
et donc comme nous nous souhaitons
égalementoup écologiste que cela aille
vite j'auris deux types de questions à
vous poser l'une en tant que membre de
la commission des finances également
rapporteur du rapport spécial transport
et puis une autre en perspective pour
mettre en relation d'autres modalités de
frit alors ma première question c'est
sur l'aide aux exploitations don vous
avez parlé avec le prolongement des
plans de relance donc 330 millions par
an puisque effectivement il y avait une
petite interrogation sur le chiffre que
vous avvez annoncé vous n dites à partir
de 2025 mais pourquoi pas à partir de
2024 euh puisque en l'occurrence je
pense que le diagnostic est posé que les
besoins sont exprimés qu'ils sont
clairement comptabiliser et que
la FR SMCF est parfaitement à même de de
conduire les premiers travaux qui
pourrai
permettre davantage de de de trafic sur
ces voies ma deuxème question c'est pour
les aides à l'investissement vous faites
état de 4 milliards entre 2023 et 2032
euh donc ma question c'est combien entre
2024 et 2027 puisque comme vous le dites
il faut que ça aille vite et que nous
partageons votre diagnostic euh deuxème
type de question c'est concernant la
question du Fred ça a été déjà abordé
par très rapidement par Madame clapau il
me semble pas paraîêtre un sujet
extrêmement important à traiter c'est la
coordination entre le frit ferroviaire
et le frit fluvial euh puisque il y a
véritablement une articulation à
conduire entre ces deux modalités euh et
donc comment vous en pensez les conduire
d'abord au plan financier déjà également
pour le frais fluvial puisqu'il y a une
vraie complémentarité des chargements
pouvant réserver ensuite le routier pour
le derniers kilomètres et puis à quant
des Assises du fret y compris sur ce
sujet du dernier kilomètre mais pas
organisé par par des associations qui se
démèent sur ces sujets mais par par
votre propre ministère je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre nous vous
écoutons merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Madame et Monsieur le Député
euh monsieur le député thébo sur
quelques points que vous avez soulevé
les autoroutes ferroviaires qui sont au
cœur de cette stratégie d'investissement
il y en a déjà cinq qui existent
plusieurs qui ont été relancé d'ailleurs
je l'évoquais par le gouvernement de de
Jean Castex par mon prédécesseur dont le
train des primeurs perpignon Ragis que
nous avons évoqué tout à l'heure c'est
le cas de Cal 7 c'est le cas de cherbour
C 7 qui est en voie d'instruction
cherbour mouer de la même façon avec un
objectif vous connaissez bien la société
lor c'est un partenariat entre deux
belles société française britaniferies
et l'entreprise l'or pour la production
des wagons et un terminal qui pourrait
être fonctionnel et un axe mise en
service nous l'espérons bien d'ici la
fin de l'année
2024 euh C Valenton qui a été mise en
place aussi d'ailleurs en lien avec le
train des primeurs dans le cadre de
cette stratégie par le gouvernement
précédent donc deux projets déjà actifs
deux qui sont encore en instruction et
en voie d'aboutissement pour lesquiv
c'est une vraie transformation c'est un
quasi doublement le nombre de nos
autoroutes ferroviaires et nos terminaux
par rapport au début de la décennie donc
tout cela en 3 à 5 ans je crois que
c'est une vraie transformation qui fait
partie de ce plan d'investiss et nous
aidons aussi par des contributions
financières d'investissement autour de
15 millions d'euros par an sur ces
différents axes vous évoquez la question
de gabarit alors c'est aussi c'est
technique c'est un un règlement européen
d'ailleurs le règlement rtet qui nous y
oblige mais je crois que c'est une bonne
chose plusieurs axes sont en train
d'être mis au gabarit c'est le cas VI
SNCF réseau pour l'axe Atlantique le cas
de cherbour mouer que nous évoquions
fait partie de ces axes qui qui seront
adapté ou nativement si je peux dire
adapté aux règles de gabarit issu de
cette réglementation P400 donc c'est un
investissement qui est en partie pris en
charge par l'État et qui est en cours de
réalisation et je pense que ça fait
partie aussi de l'avenir de nos
infrastructures ferroviaires les cûps de
connexion c'est un sujet qui revient en
effet souvent pour les instations les
installation terminale enbranché
quiévoqué aussi monsieur le rapporteur
vulfranc euh dans le cadre des CP quand
j'ai parlé d'inves pour le Fred c'est
pas toujours not triage ça fait partie
aussi des sujets ou des projets sur
lesquels il peut y avoir du
cofinancement d'État il faut à chaque
fois je pense que c'est d'ailleurs une
règle saine qui est un cofinancement de
l'entreprise mais vous avez raison
probablement de temps en temps il faut
un soutien important plus important et
probablement de temps en temps les coûts
qui sont demandés sont peut-être un peu
élevés donc c'est un un point que je
suis prêt à à regarder avec
SNCF
réseau pour répondre à vos questions
madame la députée Argi alors pourquoi
pas aller plus vite sur l'augmentation
des aides àexloitation je partage votre
sentiment là aussi d'urgence nous ferons
aussi vite que possible mais pour
reboucler avec ce que je répondais au
président jési dans un cadre sécurisé je
voudrais pas que ces aide si vous me
permettez non pas cette ironie mais
cette inquiétude potentielle on est à
discuter de leur remboursement dans
quelques années donc on va renotifier
l'ensemble pour sécuriser totalement le
paquet euh et c'est à l'issue de cette
notification qui va se faire le plus
rapidement possible que nous pourrons
augmenter péréniser et augmenter notre
soutien je suis confiant puisque nous
nous situons dans le cadre actuel déjà
validé déjà notifié mais il faut le
renouveler et l'amplifier et donc je
préfère le faire dans cet ordre-là c'est
même nécessaire et pour répondre à votre
question aussi vite que possible donc
d'abord ces aides sont déjà hauteur de
300 millions d'euros par an si je prends
l'ensemble complet wagon isolé péage et
autres on va le passer à 300 130 dès que
possible et je l'ai dit d'ici la fin
deannée 2024 et le budget 2025 si on
peut aller plus vite on le fera
évidemment mais je ne veux pas prendre
de risque qui serait regretté et
regrettable quelques mois ou quelques
années après sur les 4 milliards d'euros
d'investissement euh c'est un engagement
très important qui vous avez raison je
l'ai dit sur une décennie parce que je
pense qu'il faut donner cette visibilité
mais qui va se matérialiser dors et déjà
dans la génération de CPR que nous
négocions j'espère pour toutes les
régions que nous signerons d'ici la fin
deannée les choses ont bien commencé
avec la région Grand Est avec la région
provinciale Côte d'Azur et avec quelques
autres pour citer des régions où il y a
des investissements ant dans le fr
ferroviaire donc c'est à peu près la
moitié pour être très clair qui sera
prévu dans la période 2427 donc sur les
qu à peu près deux et la part de l'État
qui est mise dans les mandats contrat de
plan ettat région notifié par la
première ministre et moi-même au préfet
c'est un total aujourd'hui d'à peu près
900 millions d'euros pouront aller un
peu au-delà en fonction des négociations
avec les PR de régions mais l'idée c'est
de faire à peu près moitié moitié vous
connaissez la mécanique des CPR l'État
mais un peu moins de la moitié les
régions et d'autres collectivités un peu
plus de la moitié pas de règle absolue
mais c'est ainsi que ça se passe et donc
si l'État met 900 millions on peut tout
à fait raisonnablement espérer atteindre
1,1 milliard d'euros des collectivités
peut-être l'état mettra un tout petit
peu plus nous sommes prêts à en discuter
et donc en tout cas laatteinte de
l'objectif de 2 milliards d'euros c'est
bien notre objectif pour 2327 mais
paraît tout à fait bien engagé et les
premières discussions avec cagion
montrent que la priorité pour le Fred
monsieur président Valence l'a souligné
est tout à fait
partagé sur la coordination fluviale
ferroviaire quand en 2020 on a lancé à
la fois une stratégie nationale du fret
et une stratégie nationale fluviale on a
concerté ou coordonné ces deux
stratégies il y a des instance
d'ailleurs de coordination parce que
dans certains cas on peut faire ces
liens multimodau entre VNF et SNCF
réseau je vous annonce tors déjà mais
nous en parlerons dans la discussion
budgétaire que nous ferons aussi
notamment en matière d'emploi un effort
très important dans le budget pour 2024
pour VNF Mame clapou a d nous quitter
mais je sais qu'elle est aussi attachée
à la question fluviale elle l'a dit euh
nous sommes en train de réviser aussi
les dispositifs de C2E de certificat
d'économie d'énergie euh je être très
clair on peut sans doute encore faire
mieux de manière général sur la
multimodalité sur la coordination entre
les axes fluviaux et ferroviaires je
vois une zone en particulier qui est le
couloir rodanien
euh le président de la République en
déplacement à Marseille récemment a
indiqué sa priorité à cet axe
maritimo-fuvial mais aussi ferroviaire
qui est l'axe Méditerranée ronone et
j'ai la mission confiée par le président
et la première ministre d'ici la fin de
l'année de proposer une stratégie
multimodale pour le développement du
fret décarboné maritime et fluvial sur
cet axe rodanien Marseille Lyon et donc
nons l'occasion d'en reparler mais je
crois qu'on peut encore faire des
progrès pour être très clair sur les
investissements combinés en matière
fluviale et portuaire c'est pas tout à
fait notre habitude on voit d'ailleurs
même dans nos structures le port de
Marseille n'est pas en lien avec la
compagnie nationale du rô avec les
chambres de commerce et l'industrie qui
réunissent parfois les chargeurs ça
s'organise mais c'est pas encore
extrêmement naturel les assises du fret
pas m'engager dans une des processus
tous aimudes si je peux dire
mais sans les labéiser ainsi moi je suis
tout à fait prêt y compris dans vos
fonctions de rapporteur et dans les
débats parlementaires que nous aurons
notamment à l'occasion du budget à
discutter de la mise en œuvre des
stratégies fret ferroviare et fluviale
tout particulier et à voir comment on
peut accélérer augmenter la mise en
œuvre de ces
mesures il faut souligner que des
démarches de concertation de ce type
existe parfois dans certaines régions
comme c'est le cas dans le Grand Est on
va prendre trois tris questions de trois
députés tout de suite on commence par
Monsieur Nicolas sensu ensuite Monsieur
Pascal Lecamp et enfin Monsieur Marchot
monsieur sensu nous vous écoutons merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci de votre présence je vois
que vous êtes très optimiste sur la
tenue
des débats budgétaires j'espère que vous
aurez raison vous savez que des fois ils
sont un peu avortés je voudrais
souligner que vous avez dit que les
signaux positifs actuels sur le sur le
frit de ferroviaire à la fois sur le
résultat de frit SNCF mais aussi sur la
remontée du fret de ferroviaire dans le
total des des transports de marchandises
et donc c'est très surprenant et vous
l'avez dit qu' y a que 160 millions
d'euros depuis 2017 qui sont mis en
cause par la Commission européenne c'est
très surprenant que cette procédure
arrive maintenant et je trouve que c'est
même plus que surprenant que ca arrive
maintenant et ça montre à mon sens toute
la limite des traités et des règles
européennes qui entent en la matière en
contradiction avec les nécessaires
actions pour décarbonner notre économie
et nos échanges et je trouve que le rôle
de la France eû été de voir avec ses
partenaires comment changer ses règles
pour permettre justement d'arriver aux
objectifs notamment de la COP 21 parce
que si j'ai bien compris il y a des
aides qu'on va pouvoir donner maintenant
notifié validé il y avait des aides
auparavant qui n'avaient peut-être pas
été bien validé et notifié mais qui
étaient pour le coup légitime tout
autant légitime et donc des aides
légitimes mais interdites c'est ubuesque
donc vraiment j'invite le gouvernement à
prendre cette cette question au vraiment
à bras le corp j'ai quatre questions
après cela un sur la solution de
discontinuité négocié au cours de six
réunions avec la commissaire européenne
comme vous avez dit euh et qui fait
l'objet de la lettre que vous avez faite
au président farandou y a-t-il un
document qui précise l'accord de la
Commission européenne sur votre solution
proposée une lettre que l'on pourrait
obtenir au sein de cette commission
d'enquête de nous connaissons
aujourd'hui le paysage du fret
ferroviaire français avec 50 % pour Fret
SNCF à peu près 18 à 20 % pour les
filial qui auront interdiction de
candidater pendant 5 ans sur les flux
qui sont mis sur le marché alors combien
des 23 flux ont aujourd'hui trouvé
preneur j'ai bien compris que vous aviez
déjà repousser la date d'obtention au 30
juin 2024 il me a très peu tris à partir
de là y a-t-il une étude d'impact
environnemental sur le risque que cela
ferait peser de faire passer sur la
route certains de ces flux et
peut-on demander au gouvernement et à la
Commission européenne de garder au sein
de fret SNCF les flux qui n'auraiit pas
trouvé preneur ça peut être une décision
vous pourriez prendre 4 à qui reviendrai
les actifs de frais SNCF en cas de
liquidation c'estàd si on va au bout de
la procédure et qu' y a une liquidation
ça reviendrait au groupe SNCF à la SA je
vois pas comment ça peut être autrement
alors qu'est-ce qui empêcherait dans ce
cadre là de faire une nouvelle entité
publique fr qui pourrait reprendre tous
les flux de frais des
NCF merci chers collègu j'invite les
collègues à poser des questions courtes
le président Zoui nous a montré
l'exemple en début de séance de
questions Monsieur Pascal le monsieur le
député de la Vienne
merciur merci Monsieur le Ministre
d'être ici parmi nous ça va être court
parce que je voulais compléter une
question Mar vous avez donné une partie
de la réponse c'est plutôt sur les CL
lesats de plan état région donc si on
une précision il va y en avoir deux dans
les dans dans la trajectoire que vous
fixez là 2027 enfin jusquen7 28 2032 si
j'ai bien compris ce que vous avez
expliqué dans les chiffres grosso modo
le montant des 4 milliards ça serait un
peu moins de 2 milliards pour l'État un
peu plus de 2 milliards pour les
collectivités ou c'est 4 milliards de
l'État ça c'est je voudais savoir
exactement parce que euh et la deuxième
chose enfin que ça va avec he c'est tout
sur l'investissement c'est que le grand
plan de réindustrialisation de la France
dont on a besoin et qui démarrer on crée
des emplois industriels va générer de
nouveaux besoins de de de transport de
de produits qu'on exportera ou qu'on
enverra à l'extérieur dans ce plan de
réindustrialisation on aura sans doute
besoin de plus en plus de de de frais de
ferroviaire le plan tel qu'il est
proposé il prévoit de revenir finalement
à la situation de de de de 2000 où la
part modale était 18 %. c'est que une
fois qu'on a mis ces 4 milliards on
remontera du du plancher qu'on a atteint
pour revenir à la situation et
précédente est-ce que avec cette
réindustrialisation avec cette économie
qui se porte plutôt mieux aujourd'hui on
pourra penser de poursuivre cet effort
d'investissement pour que et à quel
niveau vous pensez-vous qu'il soit
envisageable d'atteindre une part modale
de de 25 ou 30 % à horizon beaucoup plus
éloigné mais est-ce qu'on peut continuer
cet effort dans le casadre aussi de la
COP 21 a éta expliqué mais de la de la
transition écologique puis après
j'aurais une petite précision sur le je
je suis pas de la région mais j'ai dans
mon passé aussi travaillé beaucoup avec
le le président du marché de Perpignan
donc l'arrivée des légumes enfin deux
marchés à chaque bout de marchés de gros
ce ce ce ce train il est fondamental
enfin pour parce que c'est toute une
économie tout un part d'économie qui
disparaît cette subvention donc que vous
avez assuré pour le maintien de de cette
de cette ligne est-ce qu'elle est-ce
qu'elle sera maintenue quel que soit je
dirais le repreneur ou le ou le
l'exploitant ou l'opérateur suivant si
ce n'était pas SNCF fat merci et donc
monsieur Mathieu martio député du he
pour
terminer une merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre une série de
questions notamment sur votre volonté de
ne pas aller à la confrontation avec la
Commission européenne y a-t-il une
certitude que Fred et sensef serait
condamné à rembourser et si oui à
qui sur une éventuelle application d'une
clause de sauvegarde qui existe déjà
dans le transport routier compte tenu de
l'engagement de la France dans la
réduction des mission lié au transport
imposé par Bruxelles le gouvernement
pourquoi le gouvernement n'envisage-t-il
pas de demander l'aménagement d'une
clause spéciale pour assurer la
pérennité de son marché du frit
ferroviaire une une question également
sur le fait que Fred etensev dans votre
plan envisagé céderait 20 % de son
chiffre d'affaires euh ce qui aboutirait
à un transfert de 10 % des effectif ce
qui équivaut à 500 emplois y a-t-il une
garantie concrète de sauvegarde de
l'emploi et est-ce que les premières
victimes euh éventuelles euh ne seraient
pas les les personnes qui ne bénéficient
pas d'un statut spécial euh de la
SNCF également une question un peu
d'avenir euh notamment sur les routes
électriques qui euh dont la question en
train de se poser qui permet de
recharger en roulant les véhicules euh
donc c'est une perspective à 10 15 20
ans est-ce que cela ne va risque pas
d'être une entrave sur le long terme au
frais de ferroviaire je sais que c'est
une expérimentation envisagé en
Allemagne en Suède et chez nous
également sur
laadis et euh également pour finir sur
la rentabilité de la nouvelle structure
puisque elle va perdre son cœur de
métier l'activité frite massive est-ce
qu'il y a pas un risque de mettre dans
le rouge cette nouvelle structure est-ce
que le gouvernement viendra en aide et
aura-t-il la possibilité de venir en
aide euh à ce nouvel opérateur public
merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre vous vouz
avoir forte affaire voà des questions
très nourries nous vous écoutons c'est
normal le sujet le mérite euh merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le Député
sensu sur les les règles d'IDE d'État
pas fait le débat tout à l'heure sur la
libéralisation complet pour le continuer
sur les règles d' d'État sansout pas
tout à fait les mêmes positions sur leur
pertinence je partage une chose avec
vous c'est qu'il est évident que le
cadre doit évoluer pas seulement sur la
question du frit notamment au moment de
la transition écologique qui nécessite
des besoins d'investissement considérabl
pas seulement publ peut-être qu'on
mettrait pas le curseur exactement au
même endroit mais évidemment public
aussi et que la multimodalité le frait
de fluvial le frais de ferroviaire
nécessite et ont auront encore davantage
des soutiens publics le règle le cadre
pardon des règles d'État européennes a
déjà évolué d'ailleurs y compris à la
faveur du plan de relance y compris sur
la question de la décarbonation ce qu'on
fait notamment je vais pas élargir trop
le champ mais sur les sous le soutien
aux batteries électriques le soutien à
l'hydrogène ça se fait par les aides
d'État massives que nous avons assoupli
si je puux dire et tant mieux par
l'action de la France en particulier
parfois de la France et de l'Allemagne
au niveau européen et donc on peut avoir
je fais le lien entre
vos démarrage et votre conclusion on
peut bien sûr faut pas faire croire le
contraire parce qu'on a ce débat
existentiel sur les 5,3 milliardes
d'euros on peut avoir des aides
publiques nationales dans la durée au
frais de ferroviaire et on leura
il faut le faire dans le cadre existant
qui a été changé qui a été assoupli et
l'exigence traditionnelle c'est que ce
cadre là soit un cadre d'intervention
publique dans lequel on soutient les
différents
opérateurs et donc ce qu'on fait avec
les aidesexplitation c'est bien avant
même la question qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui sur la procédure une aide
depuis au moins 2020 aux différents
opérateurs de frais de ferroviaire quand
vous avez néanmoins soyons très clair et
transparent une aide de wagon isolé bah
l'opérateur qui fait le plus de vagons
isolés que aujourd'hui frerccf qui
restera un opérateur ferroviaire public
demain bénéficie largement de cette aide
mais dans des conditions d'équité et de
concurrence donc tout ça pour dire que
oui on aura des aides oui on a fait déjà
évoluer le cadre je partage sans doute
avec vous le fait qu'il faudra encore le
faire évoluer mais ça nous empêche pas
qu'il faut répondre au problèm auquel on
est confronté aujourd'hui qui est pas
seulement un système comme tout État de
droit de légitimité ou de morale mais
aussi de
l'égalité mais je suis comme vous c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui réunit sans doute les
responsables politiques de tout bord le
cadre il évolue et je dis pas qu'il est
parfait dis simplement qu'aujourd'hui en
responsabilité je dois répondre à un
risque vital pour un opérateur euh et la
grande différence avec la situation que
nous avons vécu aussi ces dernières
années depuis plus de 20 ans pour Fred
SNCF quel que soi ces différentes
appellations dans le temps parce que
malheureusement il y a eu beaucoup de
restructuration c'est qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un opérateur qui est à l'équilibre
et ça s'est fait par les réformes
suexives notamment celle de 2020 et par
l'effort des agents de fr SNCF
évidemment qui rendent un services de
meilleure qualité qui sont plus soutenus
et qu'il faut continuer à
soutenir alors sur les questions
précises que vous m'avez posé en
complément documents lettres et cetera
il y a eu des échanges eurau et écrits
avec la Commission européenne la
procédure est encore en cours ce que je
dis c'est très important parce que la
question est légitime c'est est-ce qu'on
a une garane abord et on met en place la
solution après la réalité c'est qu'on a
un certain nombre de garanties je vais
revenir très précisément qui doivent
aboutir à mettre en place une nouvelle
organisation cette fameuse
discontinuité qui va et oui je suis
confiant sur ce point sinon je n'aurais
pas moi-même porter les choses devant
l'entreprise et les syndicats et les
agents aboutir je le crois une décision
positive de la commission euren cette
décision positive définitive elle ne
sera
formalisée qu'après la mise en place de
nouvelle organisation c'est aussi pour
ça qu'il faut le faire vite pour ne pas
vivre avec cette épée de damoclè
durablement je suis euh puisqu'il y a eu
ces échangesl je le dis encore une fois
en responsabilité j'ai eu des échanges
précis j'ai obtenu des garanties j'ai
obtenu un certain nombre d'accords au
pluriel on va le dire qui m'a permis le
23 mai d'aller devant les salariés en
assumant ce choix et donc je produirai
évidemment votre demande à demande de
Monsieur le Président de monsieur le
rapporteur c'est comme ça que fonctionne
notre responsabilité devant le Parlement
l'ensemble des documents et d'agenda et
d'échange que vous souhaitez aussi
précisément que possible de manière
aussi complète que possible il y a eu un
Combre de documents échangés en
effet sur les 23 flux le processus a
commencé tout début août pour être très
précis puisque il y a une procédure à
respecter à partir de la fin du mois de
mai il y a une procédure devant les
instances représentatives du personnel
engagé par la direction de Fred SNCF et
du groupe
et c'est à partir du 30 juillet c'est
une date qui avait été communiquée je
crois d'ailleurs aux agents de Fred SNCF
que les clients ont été informés d'une
probable nouvelle organisation très
rapidement qui est en train de se mettre
en place avec une date qui était le 1er
janvier 2024 et un prolongement possible
qui donne cette flexibilité pour trouver
le maximum de repreneurs jusqu'au 30
juin
2024 donc c'est en
cours l'essentiel doit encore être
attribué faut être clair mais entre le
1er août et nous sommes 1 septembre je
crois il est assez logique que tout
n'est pas encore été fait et donc je
m'engage avec l'entreprise à au fur et à
mesure des attributions vous communiquez
l'ensemble des
reprises qu'est-ce qui se passe s'il y a
pas de reprise bah d'abord il faut se
battre pour qu' le maximum de reprise
euh et que ça ne bascule pas encore une
fois d'autres opérateurs c'est un fait
mais vers un autre mode de transport
encore une fois la bataille de la
rapidité et de la petite flexibilité de
délai qu'on a jusqu'au 30 juin 2024 qui
est importante qu'on a négocié
doit permettre de trouver le maximum de
repreneurs je vais être très honnête et
très clair le cadre juridique c'est pas
que frit SNCF puisse garder les flux
donc il faut absolument c'est aussi pour
ça qu'on renforce le soutien financier
l'ensemble du secteur qui est un
repreneur dans le domaine ferroviaire
dans les mois qui viennent question
essentielle aussi je crois qu'on l'a
touché du doigt mais vous l'a précisz
c'est important parce que c'est ça qui
fait l'évaluation des choix et des
risques qu'est-ce qui se passe si on
doit à la fin de la procédure rembourser
ou même si c'est une partie de ces 5,3
milliards c'est beaucoup et qui doit
rembourser d'abord je le redis pour moi
le risque vital il est double vraiment
il est l'incertitude et l'absence de
visibilité qui est mon avis tout aussi
important que le remboursement final
potentiel et puis le remboursement final
effectivement s'il faut sortir une très
grosse somme le principe même de l'aide
d'État à rembourser c'est vrai en
agriculture c'est vrai en industrie
c'est vrai dans le ferroviaire c'est que
si la commission puis la cour de just
s'il y a des recours constate qu'il faut
rembourser mettons 5 milliards d'euros
bah c'est forcément l'entreprise qu'on a
bénéficié qui les rembourse sinon on
peut penser ce qu'on veut de la
procédure mais sinon c'est un peu chadoc
autrement dit l'État ne peut pas couvrir
le remboursement par définition donc il
faut que ça sorte des comptes d'un
entreprise quelle qu'elle soit qui est
réputé avoir bénéficié de l'aide c'est
là que le risque mortel se situe si
c'était une question de
l'État ça sera un débat je dire pour le
contribuable en quelque sorte un débat
politique important mais on pourrait
dire l'état prendra en charge on
reproche précisément à juste titre ou
non on reproche précisément à l'état
successivement d'avoir versé un paquet
d'aide représentant 5,3 milliard d'euros
à l'entreprise et c'est elle qui devra
le rembourser dans ces cas et c'est là
que je le dis très clairement là s'il y
a remboursement impératif même si c'est
pas la totalité des 5,3 milliards
d'euros c'est la mort immédiate pour
l'entreprise c'est ça le sujet c'est
aussi pour ça que je souhaite qu'on
donne un avenir maintenant à
l'entreprise en levant ce risque et dans
ce
cas-là les actifs sont dans une
procédure je préfère qu'on ait pas à
vivre ça accélérer en plus remis sur le
marché avec là beaucoup moins de chance
de trouver des repreneurs dans le même
mode de transport c'est ça qui se passe
et qui s'est passé d'ailleurs pour
certaines entreprises on parlait
d'Italia parfois de manière organisée
avec jusqu'à 50 % de session ici on est
je dis pas que c'est rien du tout loin
de là mais sur un volume de 20 % de
session avec un délai suffisant
pour le faire je pense de manière
essentielle et efficace sur ce que vous
disz monsieur Lecamp sur les chiffres je
les reprécise l'idée c'est bien 4
milliards d'euros total dont deux dans
la période 2023 2027 et en gros à chaque
génération donc là pour les 2 milliards
puis pour les 2 milliards suivants que
il y a à peu près tout est négociable
mais à peu près 50 % qui viennent de
l'État le reste des collectivités et de
l'Europe d'ailleurs parce qu'il y a des
frais il y a des financements européens
faut pas non plus que le vert à moitié
vide il y a des financements européens
qui peuvent venir mais je préfère
comptable sur ces 4 milliards d'euros
cofinancés par état et collectivité
parce que on a toujours une incertitude
sur l'obtention des financements
européens et leur rythme et leur
montants donc on peut même dépasser cet
objectif de 4 milliards mais enfin c'est
un socle qui est solide atteignable et
notamment pour les deux premiers
milliards comme je le disais madame
harigi dans les CP que nous sommes en
train de négocier avec près d'un
milliard mis déjà par l'État sur la part
modale on peut voir les choses dans les
de sens oui si on arrive de 9 à 18 % on
revient à peu près au niveau du début
des années 2000 fin de la décennie 90
euh plutôt plutôt décennies 90
d'ailleurs
euh d'autres de vos collègues ont dit
implicitement explicitement c'est déjà
très ambitieux effectivement je pourrais
vous dire on arrive à 30 % en 2030 vous
me croiriez pas vous auriez raison si on
arrive déjà à doubler la part mododale
dans la décennie je crois qu'on aura
fait une remontada si je peux dire ou
une transformation écologique massive il
y a pas de mystère non plus les choses
sont liées le frais de ferroviaire a
d'autant plus de chance de se développer
que notre industrie se
redéveloppe ce qui fait que l'Allemagne
a eu moins de difficultés à tous égards
sur le FR de ferroviaire pas de mystère
pas que les agents les Allemands sont
meilleurs que nous dans leurs services
public ou leur opérateurs public et ce
c'est qu'ils ont parfois plus investi
dans inffrastructure c'est exact mais
c'est surtout qu'ils ont connu moins de
désindustrialisation que nous donc en
menant une politique de
réindustrialisation on défend aussi le
frais de ferroviaire parce que ces
nouvelles industries plus plus vert
d'ailleurs vont aussi chercher des modes
de transport plus vert pour leur impact
ou réduire leur impact carbone est-ce
queil faut prolonger cette dynamique
au-delà de 2030 je le souhaite
évidemment et je vais être ambitieux
mais modeste atteignons déjà notre
objectif de 18 à 20 % en 2030 et puis il
faut l' d'autres stratégies euh il faut
donner la visibilité mais que ça soit
une visibilité maîtrisable si je peux
dire en pérénisant les aides à
l'exploitation jusqu'en 2030 on donne
cette visibilité nécessaire et en
faisant les investissements sur la
période
2023-2032 je crois aussi qu'on donne le
maximum de visibilité efficace qu'on
puisse donner aujourd'hui sur PERP r Oui
je vous le confirme le but c'est que le
train circule et ça c'est la garantie
qu'apporte l'État par sa subvention et
par l'appel à
manifestationintérêt dit est-ce que quel
que soit l'opérateur ccul oui circulera
quel que soit l'opérateur ça c'est notre
responsabilité je l'ai dit en réponse
dans l'émicle comme en commission oui on
maintiendra le PERP et on lance un
nouvel appel à manifestationintérêt pour
le maintenir sans subvention il ne
survivrait pas donc ça c'est la
responsabilité de l'État euh monsieur
marquio je crois avoir répondu à votre
question sur à qui on rembourse sur le
mécanisme de remboursement pardon bah
alors vous voulez préciser
euh
à ou la commion oui à l'état alors vous
me
direz que c'est une bonne nouvelle mais
l'entreprise doit le rembourser en tout
cas l'État peut pas dire euh pardon de
le dire ainsi on s'arrange et vous me le
remboursez pas si c'est constaté comme
une aide d'État à la fin de la procédure
prenant l'hypothèse que ça soit les 5,3
milliards d'euros en bloc il peut y
avoir des options intermédiaires
l'entreprise
bénéficiaire doit rembourser à l'état de
même que nous l'avons vécu
malheureusement dans certains cas en
agriculture quand il y a eu des aide au
secteur des fruits et légumes et cetera
alors ce sont les exploitations plus
petites et privées mais elles doivent
rembourser à l'état et l'État ne peut
pas se dispenser de recouvrer ces aides
donc c'est très important parce que
c'est là que réside évidemment le risque
vital et mortel
pour pour Fred SNCF euh est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir vous avez dit je crois des
des clauses spéciales ou dérogatoire euh
ça revient je crois au fond à la
question de de Nicolas sensu est-ce que
l'État peut aider le fra de ferroviaire
au fond donc faire un secteur un peu
hors marché en quelque sorte oui bien
sûr mais dans un cadre que ça c'est ma
responsabilité actuelle on s'est assuré
de respecter pour l'avenir heureusement
et oui c'est possible l'Europe comme on
dit Bruxelles n'interdit pas le soutien
public au fra de ferroviair et c'est un
secteur qui de toute façon soyons très
clair sans subvention il faut pas qu'il
y ait que des subventions il faut qu'il
y a un marché mais sans subvention ne
survivrait pas donc ça j'ai aucun
problème à l'assumer à le dire nous
continuerons à avoir un système de
soutien public au frais de ferroviaire
il le faut pour l'encourager pour
investir et pour la transition
écologique sur la question de des
effectifs poser une question précise oui
j'ai pris un engagement je l'ai dit
devant les salariés devant les syndicats
devant les direction de l'entreprise que
100 % des effectifs soient préservés
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
d'abord que le moins possible sorte de
l'opérateur actuel 90 % garanti on l'
évoqué en réponse à la question de
Monsieur le Député porte de que pour les
10 % concernés s'il ne souhait pas aller
chez un autre opérateur de fraites
ferroviaire qui reprendrait une partie
des activités c'est leur droit on leur
garantisse ça c'est une garantie
supplémentaire que j'ai demandé au
groupe SNCF d'assurer qui puisse rester
dans le groupe sur un autre métier dans
le ferroviaire public du groupe
SNCF crois que parce que je l'espère une
fois qu'on aura réorganisé les choses
l'idée c'est de mettre ça derrière nous
le plus vite possible on est un
développement de l'ensemble de
l'activité du FR ferroviaire et donc y
compris pour l'opérateur ferroviaire
public nouveau il y aura des
recrutements j'espère il y aura un
développement de l'activité il y aura
des clients supplémentaires bien ceux
qui dans les années prochaines veulent
revenir qu'on leur donne une priorité
pour qu'il réintègre l'activité de frit
ce sont deux garanties sociales
supplémentaires que j'ai demander
l'opérateur et puis dernier point vous
avez raison de le soulever il y a des
personnels statutaires dans fr SCF les
personnels contractuels je crois que
c'est à peu près 90 % de statutaire et
10 % de contractuel j'ai demandé qu'on
apporte les mêmes garanties d'emploi
elles sont donné par la loi si je peux
dire pour les personnels statutaires
mais qu'elle soit aussi garantie de la
même façon avec les trois mêmes
engagements que j'ai pris au personnel
contractuel de Fred SNF qu'on ne fasse
pas de différence à cet
égard sur le je fais un petit détour
pour rester dans le ferroviaire sur le
le cœur de métier vous dites SNCF fr
SNCF pardon perdrait son cœur de MTI non
ça j'insiste il y a partie d'activité
qui est céd je ne l'ai pas caché mais le
cœur de métier qui est la gestion
capacitaire c'est bien ça qui reste dans
fr SNCF avec une vraie viabilité j'ai
pas de doute sur ce point on l'a
démontré avec le redressement des
résultats ces dernières années et les
aides qu'on poursuivra à l'exploitation
page vagon isolé notamment dans les
années qui viennent donc c'est bien le
cœur de métier qui reste dans dans
l'opérateur de frais de ferroviaire
public qui je le redis à cette occasion
sera un opérateur à capital public
majoritaire un opérateur public
sur les routes électriques puisque
passiez vers un autre mode de transport
c'est la question plus générale de
puisquévidemment on va développer le
freit ferroviaire mais la transition
écologique ne passe pas que par le
report modal elle passe aussi par la
décarbonation de l'ensemble des modes de
transport dont la route dont l'aviation
qui sont les plus polvant notamment la
route donc il y a pas pu dire de de
choix à faire tant mieux si le fra
routier qui demeurera important et
complémentaire du FR ferroviaire en
partie sur la traget
se décarbone par la route électrique par
l'électrification des camions et cetera
on va faire ça
aussi mais soyons clair même si on
atteint et on va tout faire évidemment
pour atteindre des par modal beaucoup
plus importantes dans l'avenir au moins
les 18 % en 2030 et j'espère plus
ensuite bah il reste la majorité du FR
du frait tout court pardon qui va se
faire par d'autres modes de transport et
notamment par la route donc on a
évidemment tout intérêt à décarboné
autrement dit je crois pas que
l'investissement qu'on fait les
expérimentations vous l'avez cité sur
laad qu'on fait sur la route électrique
que ou on discutera dans le budget aussi
les efforts que nous allons faire pour
électrifier les flottes de camion soit
antifrais de ferroviaire ou
contradictoire avec l'efforts qu'on fait
dans le FR de ferroviare on fait les
deux de même qu'on investit dans le
train et qu'on décarbone l'avion parce
que on a besoin de décarboner tous nos
modes de transport le report modal est
évidemment un levier mais la
décarbonation des transports
actuellement polluant est aussi un
levier donc on fera la route électrique
on fera la décarbonation des camions
pour que le fra routier soit moins
polluant mais ça n'est pas
contradictoire et ça ne remet pas en
Cuse nos efforts budgétaires notamment
en faveur du fris ferroviaire et je
crois pas que ça l'entrave parce qu'on
sait aussi que les usages sont pas
forcément les mêmes selon la géographie
et selon les
industries merci Monsieur le Ministre on
va prendre donc deux dernières questions
l'une de monsieur le rapporteur et
l'autre de Monsieur David député des B
duô monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
en fait j'aurais pu conclure je suis
désolé il s'agit pas d'une question je
voudrais à ce stade de
notre rencontre monsieur le ministre
vous vous dire quelques éléments de si
ce n'est de conclusion quelques éléments
d'appréciation sur nos
échanges d'une part je je voudrais vous
dire que sur le fond je je m'accorderais
bien évidemment sur l'idée que dès les
années 2000 le frait de ferroviaire est
en grande difficulté même
avant mais là encore sachons de quoi on
parle nous parlons comm au niveau de la
commission d'enquête de la
libéralisation du frit de ferroviaire
mais dans un espace de libéralisation
bien plus large celui du routier qui l'a
précédé totalement libéralisé dans les
années 85- 90 et qui a ouvert droit à
cette jungle sociale et à ce dumping
social de la route qui explique en
grande partie les difficultés également
du fret ferroviaire dès ces années
premier élément
de de de comment deuxè élément du
commentaire il y a il y a un élément
avec lesquel je je suis en total
désaccord dans dans dans vos propos je
me permets de de le présenter c'est
quand vous dites que la transformation
de l'épique en SA a été totalement
neutre j'ai bien sûr sous les yeux les
arguments de la Commission européenne et
les arguments de la Commission
européenne table
je suis la logique libérale tablant sur
les les écrits de l'art à faire indique
clairement que la transformation de
l'pic en SA a porté sur les fonds
vatismau et bien une entreprise non
viable
l'arêf non viable au sens libéral du
terme tombant donc sous le
coupré des des aides européennes telles
qui sont définies
euh point
106 du
de de du point de vue de la Commission
européenne à votre plédoyer donc je suis
amené à considérer effectivement que cet
épisode de transformation de l'épique
qui était sous le coup effectivement
d'une instruction mais non pas d'une
enquête un échange d'information que la
transformation despic a et bien a de
faites autorisé à terme euh et bien que
cette esa
soit attaqué dans le cadre de la
commission d'enfê vous dites que la
réforme de et là je je tire la
conclusion que la réforme de 2018 est
validée par les bons résultats
d'activité et le redressement léger du
trafic mais elle est aussi sanctionné et
bien par le plan de discontinuité qui
déclasse de fait euh l'outil notamment
dans ces moyens voilà ma deuxième
élément de d'appréciation troisème
élément d'appréciation et j'en
terminerai là du point de vue du social
monsieur enfin il y a eu quelques
interrogations bien sûr
sur les conséquences du plan de
discontinuité nous n'avons pas répondu
personne n'a répondu sur les risques
effectivement de perte
d'attractivité de la fonction métier
notamment conducteur qui est un vrai
enjeu qu' l' qui a déjà été posé
notamment durant la période covid mais
qu'il le reste à forciuie dans une telle
séquence sur le plan du maintien d'un
opérateur public est solide bah il est
quand même
après ne plus pouvoir s'adosser sur
l'état avec la réforme de 2018 dans ses
capacités d'emprunt et quand même de
moins en moins publique puisqu'il est
ouvert à une concurrence enfin à un
intéressement privé même minoritaire
et on parie sur une viabilité nous le
souhaitons tous mais qui reste à
démontrer et enfin sur la troisième
ligne rouge que vous avez semble-t-il
posé nous n'avons pas de garantie quant
au report modal intégral des 23 flux et
à forceuie de gain de flux nouveau voilà
Monsieur le Ministre ce que je
souhaitais indiquer pour ma part en
conclusion de cet entretien en vous
remerciant euh toutefois de la précision
et de la transparence dont vous avez
fait état merci
oui je je juste une réaction il il y a
deux notions il y a la notion
d'investissement àisé monsieur le
rapporteur vous évoquez mais aussi la
notion de d'être publque dans un secteur
soumis à la concurrence qui explique la
procédure qu'on vient qu'on vient
d'évoquer qui elle n'est pas liée à la
transformation d'un ép en ça et qui
n'aurait interdit en rien que la
procédure suive son cours Monsieur David
très rapidement parce que monsieur le
ministre a une contrainte horaire et je
le remercie d'avoir déjà tiré sur le
temps qu'il nous a
accordé je vous remercie beaucoup
Monsieur le Ministre alors je vais
prolonger en fait les réflexions et et
notamment les questions pour essayer de
vous pousser dans dans vos
retranchements hein d'abord bon le frit
est un un enjeu essentiel pour la
transition écologique et je pense que le
fait que il y a que 9 % seulement de du
du commerce qui passe par le fret alors
que la moyenne européenne est à 18 % on
doit se être d'accord que c'est un
scandale en soir pour le climat c'est un
problème voilà et donc je pense qu'on
partage toutes et tous ici l'idée qu'il
faut sauver et défendre le frit de
ferroviaire néanmoins je je demeure
après l'audition pas convaincu par votre
solution et c'est bien un des cas à mon
avis où la désobéissance au traité me
semble légitime je vois pas comment on
va pouvoir réaliser la bifurcation
écologique sans essayer un minimum de
sortir de la du dogme pour moi c'est un
dogme de la concurrence libre et non
faussée notamment pour ce type
d'activité et là trois questions je
prolonge les questions de mes collègues
la première à ce jour la ce n'a pas
validé officiellement le plan du
gouvernement français je comprends vous
êtes continué à être en négociation vous
avez dit là vous espériez quand même que
la négociation aille au bout et que
votre le plan que vous proposiez soit
accepté et moi ce que je voudrais savoir
c'est votre avis qu'est-ce que cherche
la Commission dans cette négociation les
aides publiques sont possibles la
Commission européenne et l'ensemble de
l'Europe a dit qu'il fallait aller vers
la transition écologique pourquoi ils
insistent autant et ils nous menacent de
cette de cette amende et est-ce que
c'est pour affaiblir l'opérateur public
ou pas hein parce que ça c'est une
question que je me pose et ça je
voudrais avoir votre sentiment là-dessus
deuxième chose pour prolonger ça quells
sont les autres compagnies de frit qui
vont reprendre les 30 % ça ça a été dit
et redit mais vous avez l'air de dire
qu'on a euh on pense qu'ils vont pouvoir
absorber ce flux moi les infos que j'ai
c'est que eux-mêmes disent qu'ils
peuvent pas absorber ce flux donc quels
sont les éléments que vous avez en votre
disposition vous avez dit il faut mener
le combat oui mais quels sont les
éléments que vous avez à votre
disposition qui vous qui semblent
indiquer que oui ils sont cap capable de
reprendre le flux le flux et que ça
reste donc dans le fret et que ça passe
pas sur la route enfin je finirai sur le
dernier point la Commission et en réité
flexible sur la procédure quelque chose
qui a pas été dit c'est que la
commissaire actuelle Margaret westiger
se positionne pour prendre la tête de la
Banque européenne d'investissement bon
il est possible qu'elle soit remplacée
par un autre commissaire hein ça c'est
dans le paysage on peut en discuter et
dans ce cas-là il est pas le rôle du
commissaire et la place du commissaire
dans les décisions est importante moi je
pense que on pourrait tenter le coup de
de de jouer plutôt la montre hein
puisque le le calendrier n'est pas si si
ferme que ça et j'ai toujours pas très
bien compris ce qui se passait en cas de
désobéissant jusqu'au bout alors euh le
en fait la la si j'ai bien compris
l'entreprise devra rembourser les 5
milliards à l'état don qu'est-ce qui
empêche finalement ensuite l'état de
proposer à ce que ça soit la SNCF qui
reprenne l'ensemble de l'activité c'est
ce qui a dit mon collègue sANSU mais il
y a rien qui l'empêche en fait donc là
il y a quand même un jeu de dupe avec la
Commission européenne alors qu'en
réalité avec enfin la question
climatique mérite mieux que ce jeu jeu
de dupe et puis finalement ils vont
s'asseoir sur les 5 milliards enfin
parce que vous aurez accepté de de voilà
de saucissonner enfin ça paraît pour les
citoyens sincèrement et et on va aller
vers des élections européennes et la
question de l'Europe va revenir sur la
table ça paraît incompréhensible je vous
jure enfin voilà monsieur le ministre
vous avez quelques minutes mais comme il
y avait un caractère un peu itératif je
P permet de même si ça n'était pas
latéralement les question mais de
répondre sans esprit d'itération
permanente mais c'est quand même
important monsieur le rapporteur
euh non monsieur le rapporteur sur les
deux interventions
pardon répond bien sûr à monsieur le
Président chaque fois
euh je note simplement peut-être
monsieur vulfran dans dans les les deux
familles de critiques que vous faites
petite contradiction vous dites la
libéralisation abouti à des entreprises
non vibles c'est pas la libéralisation
qui a abouti des entreprises non vibles
sans refaire le débat global sur la
libéralisation l'ouverture de la
concurrence on l'a dit l'entreprise
était déjà en grande difficulté avant
avant
2006 mais surtout on peut pas avoir deux
reproches de nature opposé c'estàd être
contre l'ouverture à la
concurrence et
contester soit la modalité l'existence
d' publique je pense que vous êtes pas
en faveur de la suppression d'un système
d'aide au secteur de fret ferroviaire
l'opérateur en particulier donc pas
procher à l'état d'avoir à la fois
libéralisé et aider après la façon dont
on a aidé on voit cette procédure on
peut en discuter c'est bien ça qui nous
réunit euh mais en tout cas on n'est pas
allé dans une processus dans un
processus pardon ultralibéral dir
peut-être ainsi dans le sens où pendant
des années d'ailleurs toute sensibilité
politique confondue les gouvernements il
l'ont fait avec sincérité ont souhaité
aider le secteur et en particulier des
un opérateur qui était celui-ci donc on
peut pas dire qu'on a été dans un excès
de libéralisme un parce que les
problèmes ont commencé avant cette
mesure de libéralisation deux parce que
la réalité c'est bien le problème des 5
milliards c'est qu'il y a eu des aides
c'est un fait on n pas été dans un
système on a laissé tout seul Fred SNCF
et c'est ça qui l'aurait mis en
difficulté aujourd'hui c'est l'inverse
qui se passe par ailleurs ça répond
aussi à la question de Monsieur Davi Mo
je ne suis pas du tout un apôtre et un
fanatique de la concurrence systématique
et des et d'ailleurs c'est un
secteur je dis qui un a besoin d'aide de
a besoin d'un grand nombre de
régulations publique je crois personne
ne dit le contraire simplement si
c'était aussi simple que ça ça serait
formidable s'il aurait s'il avait suffi
de ne jamais ouvrir le secteur la
concurrence pour que Fred SNCF
ou tout opérateur public se porte bien
je signerai tout de suite mais c'est pas
la réalité les difficultés étaient très
fortes avant la chute de la part modale
massive et les autres pays européens qui
ont puis que vous avez dit qu'on est
deux fois en dessous de la moyenne
européenne je dis pas que c'est bien je
dis que c'est un fait ils ont tous un
système de fret plus libéral que le
nôtre depuis plus
longtemps donc entendons-nous au moins
sur le fait que le nœud du sujet n'est
pas que
là sinon ça serait facile on arrêterait
tout on reviendrait app ça de la
désobéissance du combat politique ce que
vous voulez on reviendrait au début des
années 2000 au début années 2000 c'était
déjà la catastrophe en terme de
parmodale tuétait bien pire
qu'aujourd'hui donc la réponse je
partage votre idée que c'est un drame
pour le climat que on développe pas
davantage le frit de ferroviaire on le
développe on peut discuter des modalités
c'est la beauté de la politique avoir
des divergences d'opinion sur les
modalités je crois que tout le monde un
est sincère pour défendre le frais de
ferroviaire de si c'était aussi facile
que libéralisation pas libéralisation ça
se serurait ça se serait vu et les
autres n'auraient pas de meilleurs
résultats que les nôtres et trois
essayons justement d'avoir un
investissement pertinent si je peux dire
soutenable à tous les sens du terme dans
les années qui viennent dans fr
ferrovière je crois qu'il passe par une
focalisation de nos aide un peu sur
l'exploitation bien sûr mais beaucoup
sur l'investissement et on l'a dit et je
ne redéveloppe pas euh
monsieur le rapporteur vulfran vous avez
posé une question j' insiste une
dernière fois quelles sont les garanties
on a commencé fin juillet donc je vous
le dirai monsieur sensu a poser la
question aussi au fur à mesure de
manière totalement transparente vous
interrogerez aussi l'entreprise sur les
repreneurs et les
reprises mais pardon là aussi comparons
ce qui est comparable si on avait pas de
procédure si fr SNCF continuait à vivre
sa vie préféit tous telle qu'on l'a
connu avant le 18 janvier 2023 vous
n'avez pas une garantie chaque année que
ça part de marché demeure donc veux dire
c'est pas comme si on avait un système
où tous les clients de fret SNCF étaient
garantis pour l'éternité ils ont la
liberté sauf si vous les nationalisez
tous euh de choisir s'ils utilisent frit
SMCF ou un autre opérateur et s'ils
utiliseent le frit de ferroviaire ou un
autre mode de transport donc ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'évidemment il faut
combattre le report modal inversé comme
on appelle ça mais de toute façon il
faut mener ce combat s'il y a pas de
procédure on aurait quand même chaque
année à faire en sorte que Fret SNCF
reste attractif que l'opérateur
ferroviaire public et le frais de
ferrovière dans son ensemble reste
attractif versus la route donc ne
faisons pas croire aux gens g peut-être
à quelques-uns qui nous écoutent que
dans un monde où il y a pas de procédure
européenne il y avait une garantie que
Fred SNCF et chaque année les mêmes
clients avec le même volume et cetera
c'est pas vrai donc le combat qu'on mène
pour garantir le report modal dans le
bon sens il est de toute façon
indispensable il se fait notamment par
le plan d'investissement que j'ai décrit
euh deux choses Monsieur David j'ai
commencé à répondre à vos questions mais
je crois qu'il y a deux éléments sur
lesquels je dois être plus précis que
cherche la Commission européenne moi je
ne fais pas partie de j'ai on peut avoir
les désaccords sur la procédure et les
arguments qui la justifient je crois pas
en tout cas je ne ferai pas ce procèslà
certainement pas qu'il a un plan caché
anti ferroviaire je crois pas il y a des
règles de concurrence penseer ce que
vous en voulez elle n'empêche pas les
aides je tiens à le rappeler ell les
cadre et elles se sont assouplies ces
règles de concurrence au fur et à mesure
c'est ça qui nous permet d'avoir ce plan
massif de soutien l'investissement et
d'exploitation aujourd'hui donc je
situerai pas le débat sur ce terrainlà
mais d'ailleurs je va tre très honnête
il ne m'intéresse pas beaucoup moi mon
sujet c'est qu'on développe le fr
ferroviaire dans notre pays cherche pas
à savoir quelles sont les intentions des
uns et les autres en tout cas je crois
que dans cette salle on partage tous
l'idée qu'on doit augmenter la part
modale du fra de ferroviaire et donc on
cherche à enlever les risques existants
et à investir pour l'avenir pour résumer
vous l'aurez compris mon ambition et mon
propos je vais être pardon très direct
jouer la montre moi je ne jouerai
pas je comprends le propos moi je ne
jouerai pas parce que c'est trop grave
et je ne vous mentirai jamais
euh peut avoir l'idée ou l'envie que
l'option
euh vous appelez ça de la confrontation
pour certains soit privilégié moi c'est
pas une question de molesse de
conciliation d'esprit de compromist
c'est une question de protection et
d'efficacité écologique et sociale et je
crois très profondément j'ai sans doute
pas réussi à tous vous en convaincre
mais je le crois très profondément que
face à une situation difficile et je
l'ai dit douloureuse d'abord pour les
salariés
la meilleure réponse c'est d'apporter
une solution rapide de lever du risque
je pas caché mon analyse je l'ai dit je
l'ai dit dans les même terme au salariés
de fr SNCF au dirigeants du
groupe qui connaissent cette affaire
évidemment en détail et qui
s'exprimeront devant vous et à vous
devant la représentation
nationale c'est pour ça que je je
bondissais un peu ne jouons pas
sécurisons les choses et je crois
vraiment
que les lignes rouges les garanties qui
sont aujourd
sur la table sont sérieuses solides je
ne dirais évidemment pas qu'il y a pas
d'effort et que c'est pas difficile
parce que pas fait spontanément mais je
le redis comme je l'ai dit en
introduction je mentiendrai là monsieur
le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur ça serait tellement plus
facile de rien faire au fond mais je
crois que vous vous me réinterrogeriez à
juste titre dans 2 ou 3 ans en me disant
vous avez tué fr SNCF je ne serai pas
celui qui a tué fr
SNCF je serai le ministre qui affronte
une difficulté en réinvestissant dans le
FR de ferroviaire et en apportant des
garanties au salariés du groupe qui le
mérite c'est ce que j'essaie de faire et
c'est ce dont j'ai essayé d'expliquer le
contenu devant votre
commission merci Monsieur le Ministre
merci de votre disponibilité pendant
2h20 avec nous et de votre volonté de
répondre précisément aux questions des
différents députés qui ont n eu la
possibil encore une fois toutes mes
excuses à ceux qui notamment
visioconférence il avit 5 collègues qui
avaient des questions n'ont pas pu les
poser merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
beaucoup